بدأ الوضع يتوتر، ما الذي حدث بالضبط؟
آخر ملوك «حمير» اسمه «يوسف أسار»
أو من أسمته المصادر العربية «يوسف بن شرحبيل، ذو نواس»
ثم اتجه إلى الوجود النصراني الأكبر، إلى نجران
وحاصر المدينة عدة أشهر. استطاع أن يقتحم المدينة
ارتكب مجزرة كبيرة
قتل كثير من أتباع الطائفة النصرانية في المنطقة
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
قراءة تاريخ أجدادنا من المواضيع المهمة لي شخصيًّا
ومحاولة فهمها من زوايا متنوعة؛ تخلي فهمها أعمق وأفضل
هذه الحلقة عن فهم تاريخ العرب والمسلمين
من وجهة نظر الأمم المجاورة
مصطلح العرب مثلًا لم يذكر إلا قريب نسبيًّا
كانوا يطلقون علينا الإسماعيليون، نسبة إلى إسماعيل عليه السلام
أو الهاجريون أو الطائيون نسبة إلى قبيلة «طيء»
فتجدهم يذكرون حتى بعد ظهور الإسلام بفترة
بأن «طائيي محمد» انتصروا في معركة «اليرموك» مثلًا
حتى لفظ المسلمين، لم يذكر عند الأمم الأخرى أول مرة
إلا بعد وفاة النبي بتسعة وخمسين سنة
طبعًا جزء من التاريخ مهم
وهو حال الجزيرة العربية قبل البعثة النبوية
فكانت النصرانية والحملات التبشيرية
انتشرت في شرق وجنوب الجزيرة العربية
حتى أن مدينة نجران، كانت أهم مركز للنصرانية في الجزيرة العربية
وكانت ملتقى صراع دُوّن في القرآن
الحلقة عن التاريخ للجزيرة العربية
لدى الأمم المجاورة وبلغاتها المختلفة
مع ضيفي الدكتور «عوض عبدالله بن ناحي»
أستاذ التاريخ الإسلامي المشارك في جامعة نجران
قبل أن نبدأ
يتخذ الإنسان قرارات كثيرة
تصل إلى آلاف القرارات في اليوم الواحد
لكن القليل من هذه القرارات مصيرية
وتؤثر بشكل مباشر على حياة الشخص ومستقبله
كيف نتخذ قراراتنا المصيرية؟
وكيف نختبرها؟ وكيف نتعامل مع نتائجها لاحقًّا؟
أسئلة مهمة، لها إجابات شافية، في طرح علمي مبسّط وشيقي
يقدمه الصديق والباحث السلوكي الاجتماعي
«محمد الحاجّي» في أحدث حلقات بودكاست آدم
رابط الاستماع في وصف الحلقة
وشكرًا لراعي الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن؛ لنبدأ
أنت تعريفك أستاذ في التاريخ المبكر، تخصصك؟
في الإسلام المبكر؟
أحسنت. الاسم طالع عندك صحيح؟
إيه. بس هذا اللي لفتني انتباهي
تصنيف الإسلام المبكر، أيش التصنيفات الأخرى؟ عطني إياها
فيه إسلام معاصر؟
فيها نقاش، المصطلح الإسلامي المبكر
هذا غالبًا مصطلح غربي في المدرسة الغربية، ليش؟
لأنه مصطلح أكاديمي يتعلق بالدراسة نفسها
دراسة التاريخ، دراسة المرحلة
فأنت تدرس التاريخ الإسلامي
يسمونه التاريخ الإسلامي المبكر الوسيط
أو يسمونه دراسة العصور القديمة المتأخرة
وهذه بتكلم عنه في موضوع التحقيب
لكن عندنا صدر الإسلام، أستاذ في تاريخ صدر الإسلام
أو أستاذ في السيرة النبوية
صدر الإسلام اللي هو عصر الرسالة والخلافة الراشدة
لكن هذا فيها خلاف
فيه ناس يقول لك العصر الأموي والأمويين، ما هم امتداد؟
وفيه ناس يقول لك لا، النظام الأموي نظام ملكي
لذلك ثقافة الحكم، الثقافة السياسية، الفكرية
اختلفت شوية عن عصر الخلافة الراشدة
لأن النظرة لعصر الخلافة الراشدة أنه عصر مثالي
في أخلاق الناس، في تعاملهم، حتى في تداول الحكم
تداول الحكم حسب منظومة سياسية محددة
قائمة على الشورى، على الاختيار
وأن الاختيار بيد النخبة السياسية
اللي هم أهل المدينة، أهل الحل والعقد
ليش نعتمد المصطلحات الغربية في تسمياتنا الأكاديمية العربية؟
لأنها مقبولة عندنا
مو غلط؟
لا، مو غلط. لأنها ما تختلف أصلًا عن دراسة المرحلة
لأن اللي بيتخصص على المستوى الأكاديمي في العصر الأموي
لا بد بالضرورة أن يتخصص في عصر النبوة، وفي عصر الخلافة الراشدة
لأنك تتكلم عن المرحلة المبكرة من التاريخ الإسلامي
عن قرن هجري فقط، ما تتكلم عن فترة طويلة
عن مئة عام فقط
بس أحيانًا ممكن أنا أبغى أتخصص في...
لأن أيش اللي يصير؟ هنا هي بتدخلنا على التحقيب
بس أن الفكرة بتخلينا ننظر لأنفسنا بنظرة الغرب لنا
لأنك لما تقسمني تاريخيًّا وفقًا للتقسيم الغربي
تخليني بالضرورة أنا أفكر فيها
بس لو أخذت أنا مثلًا ما قبل النبوة
قسم لحاله، لأنه تاريخ مختلف
ما بعد النبوة أو صدر الإسلام؛ هذا تاريخ بذاته
لو تدخل فيه، هو مختلف عنه في الأمويين
في الأمويين حصل فيه فتوحات أكثر
أصلًا انتقلت الخلافة إلى مكان آخر
وأنت ذكرت حتى اختلف شكل الحكم
بعدين العباسيين
فكل حقبة، ممكن آخذ الأمويين لحالهم بمعزل عن صدر الإسلام
وأبحثها بحث خاص فيها وللا؟
أحس أنها تخلينا ننظر لأنفسنا وفقًا للتواريخ اللي تخصنا
شوف أنت ممكن أن تركز، لكن ما تقدر تنفصل
أنا أقول خلني مثلًا أركز دراساتي على العصر الأموي
لكن بالضرورة في أي مسألة تاريخية مثلًا
لا بد أن أدرس خلفيتها وجذورها
بالتالي مثلًا جذور العلاقة بين البيتين الهاشمي والأموي
تعود إلى عصور ما قبل الإسلام
كونهم بيتين ينظمون أصلًا تحت جد واحد
هم جدهم «عبد مناف»
وهم اسمهم «بني عبد مناف»
وبيتين ينضويان تحت أسرة واحدة في الأصل
والتنافس بينهم موجود منذ العصر الجاهلي
فهذا بالضرورة لي أنا كباحث أن أعود لدراسة جذور العلاقة
بين البيتين الأموي والعباسي
حتى في العصر الجاهلي
بالمناسبة أنت تتكلم عن الغرب
حتى المدرسة الغربية تأخذ من المدرسة الإسلامية
وتستفيد منها في مسألة تحقيب التاريخ
كيف؟
على سبيل المثال
هم كان عندهم تقسيم تاريخي تقليدي، كلاسيكي نسميه
أن التاريخ ينقسم إلى: عصور ما قبل التاريخ
بعدين لما اخترعت الكتابة في بلاد الرافدين
في الألف الثالث أو الألف الرابع قبل الميلاد
اعتبروها حد فاصل، حدث تاريخي مهم
بدأت منذ ذلك العهد
أو ما سميّ بعصور التاريخ القديم أو العصور العتيقة
وصولًا إلى روما. سقوط روما بيد «الجرمان»
سقوط روما بيد «الجرمان» حدث عظيم
في تصور المدرسة الغربية أنه حدث بشري
حدث فاصل في التاريخ البشري
لكن احنا عندنا العرب لا يمثّل شيء، لا يمثل أهمية
لذلك المؤرخين المسلمين لم يعيروا انتباه
لهذا الحدث تحديدًا، أو لهذا التحقيب
من سقوط روما حتى سقوط القسطنطينية
أسموها بالعصور الوسطى
بعضهم أسموها عصور الإيمان، ليش؟
لأن الكنيسة سيطرت على الجو السياسي، الديني
على مقدرات دول في ذلك الوقت
حتى كثير من المسائل الاجتماعية، الاقتصادية، والسياسية
كانت تخضع لتأثير الكنيسة
حتى الكتابة في التاريخ صارت مقيدة، بأيش؟
بما يسمى بالتفسير الكنسي أو الديني بمشيئة الله
ما سبب هذا الحدث؟ ما سبب هذا الانتصار؟
ما سبب هذه الهزيمة؟ يقول لك مشيئة الله
ما يقدر يفسر. ويقولك لماذا هزمنا مثلًا
في معركة «اليرموك» أو في «بلاط الشهداء»
يقولك أنها مشيئة الله
والمفارقة خلنا نسميها أن معظم المؤرخين الغربيين وقتها
كانوا من رجال الكنيسة
على عكس المسلمين، لا
منهم رجال دين، منهم تجار، منهم مثقفين، منهم أدباء، منهم رجال بلاط
يكتبون في التاريخ
بل أن حرية التفكير التاريخي عند العرب أعلى بكثير من الغرب
أيضًا عندك مسألة مهمة، خلنا نرجع لموضوع التحقيب
المؤرخين الغربيين انتبهوا لمسألة أن الفتوحات الإسلامية
غيرت الخارطة السياسية والدينية والحضارية للعالم القديم
بدل ما تكون عندك إمبراطورية فارسية وإمبراطورية رومانية أو بيزنطية
يعني قوتين عظميتين
وحدة خرجت من الوجود وهي الدولة الفارسية
الأخرى أصبحت كيان إقليمي، وهي الإمبراطورية البيزنطية
الخارطة السياسية أمامك في أقل من نصف قرن؛ تغيرت
فلذلك فيه مؤرخ إيرلندي اسمه «بيتر براون»
كتب كتاب اسمه «عالم العصور القديمة المتأخرة»
هو يقول أضروحة
يقول أنا ما أتفق مع الطرح الغربي التقليدي أو الكلاسيكي
أنا أرى أن العصور القديمة ظلت مستمرة
حتى ظهور العرب أو الرسالة السماوية وظهور الإسلام
وأرى أن ظهور الإسلام وأن نبوة محمد عليه الصلاة والسلام
وما تلاها من أحداث عظيمة
هذا هو الحدث الفاصل اللي غيّر في التاريخ البشري
هذا التصنيف تبناه مجموعة من المؤرخين الأوربيين
أو الغربيين بشكل عام اللي أتوا لاحقًّا
في بريطانيا، في أمريكا، في فرنسا، كانت لهم أطروحاتهم
أصبح هذا المصطلح مرتبط العمل الأكاديمي
ليس بالضرورة مثلًا أن يقول لك
أنا متخصص في التاريخ الإسلامي وفي الوسيط
يقول أنا أستاذ العصور القديمة المتأخرة
أعطيك على سبيل المثال
عندنا أستاذ استضافته بعض المؤسسات عندنا في المملكة
هيئة التراث أو إدارة الملك عبدالعزيز اسمه «روبرت هويلند»
«روبرت هويلند» أهم متخصص في التاريخ الإسلامي المبكر اليوم
في البايو ولما تدخل عنده اليوم في جامعة نيويورك
تجده كاتب أستاذ التاريخ الإسلامي والعصور القديمة المتأخرة
ستجد أنهم نحّتوا هذا المصطلح
هذا المصطلح ما كان موجود قبل
قبل خمسين سنة ما كان موجود مصطلح العصور القديمة المتأخرة
هذه العصور القديمة المتأخرة هي اللي ما بعد بداية الإسلام؟
لا، هي تبدأ من سقوط روما عام 476
حتى ظهور الإسلام أو بداية الفتوحات
حتى 632، وفاة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
اعتبروا أن هذا أيش؟ حدث فاصل
وبكذا أزال القسطنطينية صح؟
كيف؟
سقوط القسطنطينية
لا، سقوط القسطنطينية هو عام 1453
هذا حدث يعتبر في تصورات المدرسة الغربية
حدث فاصل ما بين العصور الوسطى والعصور الحديثة المبكرة
أيش الكلاسيكية؟ أبغى أشوف كيف الغرب يحقبون التاريخ عندهم
هم كيف يحقبون التاريخ؟
يقول لك هناك عدة فترات طويلة متباينة
لعصور ما قبل التاريخ، عصور الإنسان البشري البدائي
اللي حتى ما كانت فيه كيانات سياسية، ولا معالم واضحة للتاريخ
الإنسان وقتها كان يعيش حياة بدائية
هذه اسمها عصور ما قبل التاريخ
هذه العصور تمتد حتى اختراع الكتابة في بلاد الرافدين
أو ما تسميه المدرسة الغربية بالشرق الأدنى القديم
اللي هو يشمل منطقتنا العربية والشرق الأوسط اليوم
هذا حدث فاصل
هذه الفترة تمتد إلى سقوط روما بيد «الجرمان»
لأن سقوط روما أنهى كيان سياسي كبير
اسمه الإمبراطورية الرومانية الغربية
وأحدث تغيير سياسي وديني وفكري وحضاري وبشري
بسيطرة قوميات جديدة على روما
من عام 476 حتى سقوط القسطنطينية في أيدي الأتراك العثمانيين
هذه سموها العصور الوسطى
عصور الإيمان، عصور الظلام
هناك مؤرخين سموها عصور الظلام
يقولون لك هذه ما نعتبرها احنا عصور الظلام
لأن الكنيسة حرمت الفلسفة، حرمت العلوم التطبيقية
حرمت دراسة الكيمياء، حرمت دراسة الفيزياء
احتكرت حتى الكتابة التاريخية والأدبية
على رجال الكنيسة وعلى رجال الدين
سيطرت على المؤسستين: التعليمية والسياسية
وكثير من مؤسسات الدولة
فهي بالتالي عصور ظلام، لأنها عطّلت الفكر الغربي
على عكس ماهو موجود في العالم العربي
أو في العالم الإسلامي وقتها
الدولة تشجع على الحركة العلمية، على الترجمة
على دراسة الفلسفة، على حركة الترجمة
على دراسة العلوم التطبيقية أو التجربية
ما كان هناك سقف بالنسبة للدولة
نتكلم عن الدولة العباسية في مسألة الحركة الفكرية
كان السقف عالي جدًّا
مثلًا علم الفلسفة رغم ما أحدثه هذا العلم
من خلافات فكرية، وخلافات مذهبية
من ظهور فرق فكرية مثل فرقة المعتزلة
فرقة فلسفية دينية تقول بخلق القرآن
لكن هذه الفرقة لها إنتاج فكري كبير وعظيم
المفارقة هنا، ومثل ما ذكرت لك قبل قليل
أن حتى الكتابة التاريخي كانت مزدهرة جدًّا
كثير من اللي يكتبون التاريخ
صحيح أنهم فقهاء، لكنهم بفكر تقدم هنا
هم كانوا يعملون النقد. وكانوا يجمعون الكثير من الروايات
كانوا يعتمدون منهجيات متباينة في التأليف التاريخي
وهذه مسألة مهمة، ورغم أيضًا ارتباطهم بأيش؟
بالتفسير الإسلامي للتاريخ
نجي للمسلمين، بس ودي نقفل للغرب
فهم هذه العصور عصور الظلام أو عصور الإيمان
أيوة
وبعدها؟
بعدها تبدأ العصور الحديثة، كيف تبدأ العصور الحديثة؟
حركة الكشوف الجغرافية
بعض المؤرخين الغربيين يرى أن هي الحدث الفاصل
اللي يؤرخ ببداية العصور الحديثة
من إسبانيا، ومن البرتغال انطلقت مجموعات
لاستكشاف العالم الجديد، استكشاف الشرق
«فاسكو دي قاما» «كولومبوس»
وقتها اكتشفت الأمريكيتين واكتشفت أستراليا
اكتشف «رأس الرجاء الصالح»
وكانت أسباب هذه الحركة دينية، اقتصادية، سياسية
في المجمل كانت بروح صليبية
لأن الدافع ديني كان محفز وقتها لإسبانيا وللبرتغال
وبدعم من البابوية، لهذه الكشوف الجغرافية
في بعض التفسيرات أن جزء من حركة الكشوف الجغرافية
هو لمطاردة المسلمين
هو لحصار العالم الإسلامي. هو للوصول إلى مكة
وبالفعل كانت فيه حملة برتغالية وصلت إلى حدود جدة
في القرن العاشر الهجري
بعد 950 أو في النصف الثاني من القرن العاشر الهجري
وصلت حملة برتغالية إلى جدة
كان هدف هذه الحملة مكة والمدينة
المدينة بالضرورة الأولى
وقبر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كهدف استراتيجي لهم
وهذا ما يؤكد لك عن وجود روح صليبية في حركة الكشوف الجغرافية
في محاولات الامتداد الغربي إلى العالم الإسلامي
طبعًا القوتين أتكلم عن إسبانيا وعن البرتغال
تراجعتا أمام قوة ناشئة طموحة جديدة
بعد ذلك بقرنين، هي إنقلترا
بعد معركة اسمها معركة «الأرمادا»
تغيّر ميزان القوة السياسية والعسكرية
من إسبانيا إلى بريطانيا العظمى أو إنقلترا
اللي ورثت كثير من المستعمرات الإسبانية
وبدأت عبر شركة اسمها شركة «الهند الشرقية»
تتغلغل مثلًا في الهند
اللي هي درة التاج البريطاني
تتغلغل في كثير من مناطق شرق آسيا
وصلت إلى الخليج العربي
بعد عصر النهضة، هل تغيّر تحقيب التاريخ بنسبة للغرب؟
هو أنت تتكلم عن التحقيب في وقتنا اليوم
هناك خلافات، هناك جدالات، هناك نقاشات
مثل ما ذكرت لك قبل قليل، نظرية «بيتر براون»
أعادت مسألة التحقيب عند الغرب، ووجدت قبول
لأن ليس بالضرورة أن عام 476 هو حدث فاصل
احنا عندنا أحداث أخرى ممكن على ضوءها نعيد تحقيب التاريخ
مثلًا ظهور الإسلام على سبيل المثال
الحروب الصليبية، سقوط الأندلس
وخروج المسلمين من الأندلس؛ حدث مهم
حدث مهم خاص بالنسبة للعالم الإسلامي
و أنا ما ودي أدخل في العالم الإسلامي، ودي أظل في الغرب
أيضًا على سبيل المثال
هناك خلافات بين المدرسة الغربية نفسها
في تحقيب التاريخ بالنسبة للدول
مثلًا في بريطانيا، عندهم فترة متمايزة اسمها الحقبة «الفكتورية»
والتي خلالها كانت بريطانيا في أوج تألقها وسيطرتها الاستعمارية
الحقبة «الفكتورية» لا تمثل شيء لدولة مثل أمريكا أو فرنسا أو ألمانيا
مثلًا تأسيس ألمانيا، يعتبر عند الألمان منذ أيام «بسمارك»
حدث فاصل في تاريخهم
لكن ليس بالضرورة أن يكون عند الإنقليز أو عند الفرنسيين حدث فاصل
مثل ما أن عندنا نحن العرب ليس شيء
أو ليس بالضرورة أن يمثل لنا أي شيء
صحيح
هذا حدث يخص هذا الدولة
ستجد أن تحقيب التاريخ في المجمل
يخضع للخلفيات السياسية والدينية والحضارية للأمم
أو للحضارات بشكل عام
كيف كان التحقيب عند المسلمين؟
التحقيب عند المسلمين له فلسفته المختلفة
اللي يرتبط أصلًا بنشأة علم التاريخ عند المسلمين نفسهم
علم التاريخ لمن لا يعلم، هو علم عربي إسلامي أصيل
هناك علوم أُخذت أو أُستوردت من أمم أخرى
مثل الفلسفة وبعض العلوم التطبيقية مثل الكيمياء أو الرياضيات
لكن علم التاريخ، علم عربي أصيل، كيف خرج؟
التاريخ، لو تعود إلى الحركة الفكرية والحركة العلمية
في صدر الإسلام، في عصر النبوة، وعصر الخلافة الراشدة
ستجد أن هناك حركة علمية منظمة وواضحة
أو حركة طلب العلم، أساسها المسجد
المسجد ذلك الوقت كان يمثّل المدرسة
كان يمثّل الجامعة، كان يمثّل المؤسسة التعليمية
لأن حلقات الدرس تعقد في المسجد
والتركيز كان مُنصَب على دراسة العلوم الشرعية
أولها القرآن، ثم دراسة الحديث
والحديث هو ما أُثر عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من فعل، من قول، من تقرير، من صفة بمعناه الشامل
من مدرسة الحديث تجذّر علم التاريخ
فالقرآن يحث على الاقتداء بسيرة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ومن هذا المنطلق حرص الكثير من الصحابة، من التابعين
من الأجيال المبكرة في هذه الحقبة
على جمع مرويات سيرة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
مغازيه، على درستها، على الاستفادة منها
لأغراض كثيرة، سواءً لأغراض دنيوية أو لأغراض أخروية
على سبيل المثال، العطاء
العطاء اللي نسميه اليوم الراتب
جزء كبير منهم حرص على أن يعرف
ماذا قدمت أسرته في فترة النبوة
وبالتالي كان كثير من التابعين حريصين
على دراسة السيرة النبوية كجزء من هذا السياق، على سبيل المثال
كانوا حريصين على دراسة السيرة النبوية
لن أقول لك لأسباب دنيوية، ولكن لأسباب علمية
هذا الموضوع تطور مع الوقت
إلى محاولة تدوين السيرة النبوية والمغازي
في سياق حركة التدوين
لأن في الفترة هذه كانت وسيلة الدراسة
ووسيلة العلم هي المشافهة
متى بدأ التدوين؟
بدأ التدوين نهاية القرن الأول الهجري
ذلك الوقت أدوات الكتابة كانت معدومة
وهذا السبب في عدم وجود التدوين
هو ليس كل الأسباب، هناك أسباب متعددة
لكن ندرة أدوات الكتابة، ما في ورق ذاك الوقت
ما في إلا الرق الجلد، ما في إلا الحجارة
ما في أدوات تدوين كثيرة
فلما بدأت أدوات الكتابة تتوفر
لما بدأت دواعي التدوين تتوفر أيضًا
أصبح هناك توجه لتدوين المغازي، تدوين السيرة
في السياق اللي دُوّن فيه الحديث، وقبل ذلك دُوّن القرآن
فظهر عندنا مجموعة من أبناء الصحابة
مثل «عروة بن الزبير بن العوام» «أبان بن عثمان بن عفان»
كلاهما تابعين جليلين من أبناء الصحابة
«أبان بن عثمان بن عفان» أبوه هو الخليفة الراشد
«عثمان بن عفان» ثالث الخلفاء الراشدين
«عروة بن الزبير بن العوام» ابن الصحابي «الزبير بن العوام»
ورجل له شأنه في الأوساط العلمية، في الأوساط حتى السياسية
لكن اتجه لطلب العلم والجانب العلمي في أواخر حياته
فدوّن المغازي
شخصيات أخرى مثلًا عندنا «وهب بن منبه» من اليمن
وهو من أصول فارسية بالمناسبة
«شرحبيل بن سعد» «عاصم بن عمر بن قتادة»
مجموعة كبيرة حاولت أن تُدوّن
مغازي الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وسيرته
للأسف كل هذه المحاولات اندثرت
لم تصل إلينا إلا بطريقة غير مباشرة
كيف؟
ظهر جيل ثاني بعدهم حاول أنه...
بس أيش اللي حصل عليهم؟ وليش اندثرت؟
اندثرت مثل كثير من التراث الإسلامي
بسبب أنها لم تنسخ أو لم تتداول
أو لم تجد من يحفظها بسبب عواجز ما بشكل عام
وكيف وصلت لنا بطريقة غير مباشرة
عبر المؤرخين المبكرين للسيرة النبوية
على سبيل المثال، مرويات «عروة بن الزبير»
موجودة إلى اليوم في أمهات الكتب
كتب التاريخ الإسلامي، مرويات أنا أتكلم على سبيل المثال
الجيل الثاني أو الجيل الثالث حاول أن ينتقل إلى مرحلة أهم
اللي هي إخراج عمل كامل
أيش تقصد؟
أقصد مثلًا كتاب التاريخ في السيرة النبوية
كيف ذلك؟
موضوع تدوين السيرة مثل ما ذكرت أنه تطور
إلى أن وصل إلى مرحلة تدوين العمل كامل
من خلال جمع كل هذه المرويات
جمعها في سياق واحد، في ترتيب واحد
بدل ما يقول لك أنا بألّف في المغازي فقط، مغازي الرسول
يقول لك لا، أنا بألّف في السيرة النبوية كاملةً
لذلك خرج لدينا مجموعة من الأعمال
في نهاية النصف الأول من القرن الثاني الهجري
أهمها على الإطلاق كتاب «المبتدأ والمبعث والمغازي»
لـ «محمد بن إسحاق بن يسار»
«محمد بن إسحاق بن يسار» كتب أهم كتاب في السيرة النبوية
والذي عرف لاحقًّا بسيرة «ابن إسحاق»
لكن هو أسماه «المبتدأ»
أشار فيه إلى إسماعيل وإبراهيم عليهما السلام، وقصة بناء الكعبة
أشار إلى بدء الخلق قبل ذلك
وصولًا إلى جاهلية العرب، وأهم الأحداث التي حدثت في العصر الجاهلي
مثل محاولة هدم الكعبة
مثل انتقال «قصي بن كلاب» إلى مكة
وانتقال «قريش» إلى مكة وإخراجها «خزاعة»
مثل حادثة «الأخدود» والغزو الحبشي لجنوب الجزيرة العربية
انتقلت «قريش» من وين إلى مكة؟
هذه فيها جدال تاريخي
«قريش» كانوا عبارة عن أشتات، خرجوا منذ وقت غير معلوم
ثم جاء «قصي بن كلاب» وهو جد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم الرابع
الذي جمع هذه القبيلة جمع شملها
وكانوا عبارة عن بادية
ثم أنه دخل في صراع مع قبيلة «خزاعة»
هذا الصراع انتهى في النهاية إلى انتصار «قصي بن كلاب»
وإخراج «خزاعة» من مكة
وتولي «قريش» أمر الحجابة، السقاية، الرفادة
أمر إدارة مكة والكعبة الشريفة
لأن الحج فريضة كانت موجودة عند العرب قبل الإسلام
طيب، ودي أرجع للـ 150 سنة اللي غاب فيها التدوين
أيش أثرها على تاريخ المسلمين، غياب التدوين هذه الفترة الطويلة؟
هي مرحلة تأسيسية
صحيح أن لما تطالع الكتب اللي أرّخت لحركة التدوين عند العرب
أو ما نسميه بفهارس الكتب
ستجد أن كثير من هذا التراث اللي دُوّن في هذه الحقبة المبكرة؛ ضاع
لكن كشكل عام، هذه كانت مرحلة تأسيس
لأن فيه حركة علمية
فيه حفظ للعلوم نفسها عبر الرواية الشفهية
بل أنه ظهر علم نسميه علم الجرح والتعديل
أيش هذا؟
هذا العلم يهتم بالرجال، بالرواة نفسهم، بدراسة موثوقية الرواة
فلذلك صنّف الرواة على حسب مصداقيتهم
ثبت، ثقة، حسن، صدوق، كذوب، ليس بشيء مثلًا
هذا هو التصنيف الموجود
لذلك علم الجرح والتعديل كان مهم جدًّا
في فرز أو تنقيح المرويات
خاصة مرويات الحديث النبوي الشريف اللي وصلت إلينا
فكان هناك حركة علمية منظمة
أداتها أو وسيلتها هي التداول الشفهي
لأسباب طبعًا. لسبب عدم التدوين مثلًا
أنا ذكرت لك مثلًا ندرة أدوات التدوين، هذا سبب مهم
لكن أيضًا توجهات السلطة نفسها
مثلًا الخليفة «عمر بن الخطاب»
وقبل توجه الدول، من عصر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
أن التدوين يكون حصرًا على القرآن الكريم
وسبب ذلك حتى لا يختلط القرآن بالحديث
أنه خلونا يا جماعة نركز على تدوين القرآن وعلى حفظ القرآن
إلى أن جاء الخليفة «عثمان بن عفان»
فأقدم على خطوة كانت فاصلة
أنه وحّد جميع المصاحف على خط واحد، وعلى نمط واحد
وعلى مصحف واحد، على نسخة واحدة
هذه النسخة نُسخت منها نسخ كثيرة
بعدها بدأ الامر يتحول إلى موضوع التدوين
تدوين الحديث الشريف، كانت خطوة مهمة
نستذكر مثلًا أن الخليفة «عمر بن عبدالعزيز»
على رأس المئة، هو حكم من عام 99 - 102 للهجرة
أمر «أبوبكر محمد بن عمر بن حزم»
و هو من علماء التابعين في المدينة المنورة
أن يدوّن له أحاديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكانت هذه محاولة مهمة
طبعًا هذه المحاولة لم يكتب لها النجاح
لأسباب اختلف المؤرخون حولها
قيل أن الخليفة تراجع وأمر بحرقها
قيل أنها اندثرت أو ضاعت
لكنها كانت محاولة مهمة أشار لها مجموعة من المؤرخين
لكن ستجد أن حركة تدوين السنة النبوية
بدأت تتسارع إلى تدوين أعمال كاملة
مثل «الموطأ» لـ«مالك بن أنس»
و«مالك بن أنس» مؤسس المذهب المالكي، كان في المدينة المنورة
والمدينة المنورة ظلت أهم مركز علمي حتى القرن الثاني للهجرة
سواءً لدراسة السيرة النبوية، لدراسة القرآن
لدراسة العلوم الفقهية، لدراسة التاريخ
«محمد بن إسحاق بن يسار» هو من مدرسة المدينة
لأنه ولد ونشأ وترعرع، وطلب العلم في المدينة
وبسبب خلافاته مع بعض كبار المدرسة العلمية في المدينة
أو مع بعض كبار الرجال في المدينة
وبسبب منهجيته في كتابة السيرة النبوية، وبسبب علاقاته
دخل في صراعات ودخل في خلافات
أدّت في النهاية لخروجه من المدينة المنورة إلى العراق
فتنقل إلى أن استقر في بغداد
وقيل أن الخليفة «أبو جعفر المنصور»
طلب منه أن يكتب له عمل في السيرة النبوية
بسبب توجهه لهذا المجال، وتركيزه على هذا المجال
وبالفعل أخرج له كتاب السيرة النبوية
التي عرفت لاحقًّا باسم «سيرة ابن إسحاق»
أو ما عُرف بكتاب «المبتدأ والمبعث والمغازي»
من المآخذ اللي أُخذت على هذا الكتاب
أنه ضمّن الكثير من الإسرائيليات والشعر المنحول
والأخبار التي لا يقبلها العقل
لذلك أتى «عبدالملك بن هشام المعافري» فهذّب هذه السيرة
حذف منها الإسرائيليات. وأنا بشرح لك الإسرائيليات
حذف منها الشعر المنحول اللي ما يُصدّق
أو الأخبار التي لا تصدق
واختصرها، واخرجها لنا في قالب
اسمه السيرة النبوية لـ«عبدالملك بن هشام»
هذا الكتاب موجود اليوم عندنا، وموجود في المكتبات
لكن الأصل اللي كتبه «ابن إسحاق» أغلبه لم يعد موجود
ممكن فيه قطعة من هذا الكتاب مخطوط
عثر عليها المؤرخ «محمد حميد الله» حققها ونشرها
ولعل السؤال اللي يمكن في بالك عن الإسرائيليات
ماذا تعني الإسرائيليات؟
الإسرائيليات هي ما أُثر عن بني إسرائيل، عن اليهود
من أخبار، من قصص تتعلق بالأنبياء، تتعلق بماضي بني إسرائيل
بأخبار الأمم السالفة
أخبار كثير منها أسطورية، قد لا يقبلها العقل
لكن كثير من المدونين الأوائل
أخذوا بحديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
«حدثوا عن بني إسرائيل ولا حرج، ومن كذب علي متعمدًا، فليتبوأ مقعده من النار»
فهم أخذوا هذا الحديث كحجة في تدوين الإسرائيليات
ثم لو أتينا إلى مرحلة التحقيب
قبل ما أنتقل إلى تطور الكتابة التاريخية
ستجد أن التحقيب ارتبط بهذه الكتابة
كيف نظرة المسلمين للتاريخ؟ وكيف يتم تحقيبه؟
هذه النظرة تأثرت بما ورد في القرآن الكريم
من قصص، من أخبار الأنبياء، وأخبار الأمم السالفة
فبناءً على هذا التصوّر؛ بنى المؤرخين المسلمين
تصورهم للتاريخ والتحقيب بالتاريخ
أن التاريخ يبدأ من عهد آدم عليه السلام
خلق البشر ونزول آدم وحواء من الجنة إلى الأرض
ثم وصولًا إلى عهد نوح عليه السلام والطوفان
وهذه مرحلة فاصلة عند المسلمين
وفي المقابل أيضًا عند مؤرخي الكنيسة
أو الكنائس الشرقية النصرانية أو الغربية
ومن عهد نوح إلى عهد إبراهيم عليه السلام
وابنه إسماعيل وبناء الكعبة المشرفة؛ حدث تاريخي فاصل
ومن بناء الكعبة الشريفة حتى نبوة موسى عليه السلام
داود بن سليمان أيضًا حدث أو أحداث أو حقب متباينة متمايزة
وصولًا إلى عهد السيد المسيح عليه السلام؛ حقبة متمايزة
ومن عهد السيد المسيح إلى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
حقبة متمايزة اسموها اصطلاحًا بالعصر الجاهلي
رغم أنك حينما تتجول في كثير من مناطق المملكة اليوم
ستجد أن هناك آلاف النقوش
يعني هناك حركة تدوين، هناك فكر
لكن العصر الجاهلي هي من منطلق أنه لا يوجد هناك توحيد
الوثنية هي السائدة على الناس
هناك فوضى دينية وفوضى سياسية
وصولًا إلى عهد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم؛ هذه تعتبر حقبة متمايزة
بعد عهد الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كانت فترة النبوة في رأي المؤرخين المسلمين
حقبة متمايزة والحقبة الأهم في التاريخ
التي أعطوها القدر الأكبر من اهتمامهم
ثم يأتي عصر الخلافة الراشدة، العصر الأموي، العباسي بحقبه الأربع
وصلًا إلى سقوط الأندلس
الذي يعتبر عند كثير من المؤرخين المسلمين والعرب اليوم
حدث مهم في مسألة التحقيب الثالث
فيه نقطة، الحين أنت ذكرت أن المؤرخين بدأ اهتمامهم
بتوثيق وتدوين السيرة
نعم
هل تطور وصار التدوين سواءً للحركة السياسية
في العهد الأموي أو العباسي وللا ما بعده الفاطمي وغيره
أو حتى عن الفتوحات، هل كان المسلمين يدونون الفتوحات الإسلامية؟
جميل، هذا سؤالك مهم وجوهري
لأنه يتعلق بتطور علم التاريخ عند المسلمين
أنا ذكرت لك، أن تدوين السيرة هو الأساس الذي ينطلق منه علم التاريخ
هذا المسألة كانت أساس بدأ من خلاله المؤرخين المسلمين
يهتمون بالتأريخ لحقب لاحقة أو لأحداث مفصلية
أو لتطبيق أطروحات أو منهجيات جديدة في التدوين التاريخي
ظهر هناك توجه مثلًا لتدوين أخبار الخلفاء الراشدين
أو مرحلة الفتوحات المبكرة، الفتوحات الإسلامية
أو حتى للتأريخ لبعض الأحداث المفصلية
مثلًا عندنا كتاب «فتوح البلدان» لـ«البلاذري»
هذا الكتاب في الأصل أُلّف للتأريخ لحركة الفتوحات
لكنه تضمن كثير من أحداث التاريخ الإسلامي المبكرة
وأرّخ فيه «البلاذري» للسيرة النبوية
وركز تحديدًا على علاقة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم مع أهل الذمة
مع النصارى مع اليهود مع الزردشت
طبعًا هم لهم تصنيف آخر
طبعًا أهل الذمة اللي هم اليهود والنصارى
ظهرت هناك كتب في تواريخ البلدان
مثلًا «تاريخ المدينة» لـ«عمر بن شبّه»
هذا الكتاب اختص بالتاريخ للمدينة المنورة
«أخبار مكة» لـ«أبي الوليد الأزرقي»
أو «أخبار مكة» لـ«محمد بن إسحاق الفاكهي»
مثلًا اختص بكل ما يخص هذه المدينة المقدسة منذ عصورها العتيقة
كتاب «تاريخ بغداد» مثلًا «الخطيب البغدادي» ولاحقًّا «تاريخ دمشق»
فظهر هناك التاريخ للمدن
طهر هناك التاريخ لأحداث سياسية محددة مثل حروب «الردة»
حروب «الردة» كانت حدث مهم وخطير في مرحلة حرجة
لأنها بدأت في الأيام الأخيرة لحياة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتصدى لها الخليفة «أبوبكر الصديق» في مرحلة حرجة
واستطاع أن ينجح في التصدي لها
وتحويل مقدرات الدولة وإمكانياتها للفتوحات
فظهرت لنا مؤلفات مثل كتاب «أخبار الردة» لـ«الواقدي»
«محمد بن عمر بن واقد» ألّف كتاب اسمه «أخبار الردة»
مثلًا «الجمل» و«صفين» هناك من أرّخ لهما
هناك من أرّخ للرجال أو للطبقات
أو أقرب شيء نسميه له اليوم السيرة الذاتية
فظهر لنا مثلًا كتاب اسمه «الطبقات الكبرى» لـ«محمد بن سعد بن منيع»
«محمد بن سعد» قال أنا ما بكتب كتاب تاريخ عام
أنا بأرّخ للطبقات. بأرّخ للسيرة النبوية ثم أترجم للصحابة
اللي هي السيرة المختصرة لكل صحابي
مولده، نشأته، أصوله الاجتماعية أو القبلية
سيرته مختصرة إلى وفاته
ثم أرّخ للتابعين، وهكذا
وكذلك طبقات «خليفة بن خياط»
ظهر لدينا من حاول أن يطبّق فكرة التاريخ العالمي
أو يؤرّخ للبشر، هي سميت بكتب التاريخ العام
لكن كان فيها محاولة لكتابة التاريخ البشري، إذا صح التعبير
طبعًا كانت فيه محاولات لـ«خليفة بن خياط» لـ«الهيثم بن عدي»
لـ«أحمد بن واضح بن يعقوب» لـ«اليعقوبي»
لكن أهم محاولة لكتاب موجود
ويعتبر أهم مصدر احتوى كثير من التراث المفقود
اللي أنت أشرت له قبل قليل
اللي هو تاريخ «الرسل والملوك» لـ«محمد بن جرير الطبري»
هذا الكتاب أرّخ فيه هذا الرجل وحقق فيه للعالم ككل
منذ خلق آدم عليه السلام
و أرّخ فيه للإمبراطوريات السابقة اللي سبقت العرب
إمبراطورية الفرس الأولى أو الإمبراطورية الخمينية
إمبراطورية الفرس الأخيرة اللي هي إمبراطورية الساسانية
الإمبراطورية اليونانية الإغريقية، الإمبراطورية الرومانية
الممالك اليونانية اللي أتت بعد «الإسكندر»
الممالك العربية التي سبقت ظهور الإسلام
«المناذرة» «الغساسنة» «كندة» في وسط الجزيرة العربية
ممالك جنوب الجزيرة العربية
أرّخ فيها حتى للصين، أرّخ فيها حتى لأوربا
حاول أن يقدم فكرة كيف نكتب تاريخ عالمي
وتبنّاه على المنهج الحولي
واستوعب فيه كثير من المرويات
لكن التاريخ الإسلامي أو عصر النبوة والخلافة الراشدة والفتوحات
حضيت بالاهتمام الأكبر
لذلك كل من يتخصص في هذه المرحلة
اللي سألتني عنها قبل قليل، مرحلة الإسلام المبكر
لا بد أن يعود إلى هذا المصدر المهم اللي هو «تاريخ الطبري»
كثير من التراث مفقود
مثلًا عندنا مؤلفات مؤرخ اسمه «أبي مخنف لوط بن يحي الغامدي الأزدي»
هذا الرجل مؤرخ وهو محسوب على التيار الموالي
للخليفة «علي بن أبي طالب» رضي الله عنه
أو تيار الشيعة كما يقولون. هذا المؤرخ أعماله مفقودة
مثل «عوان بن الحكم» و هو مؤرخ محسوب
على الفريق الموالي لبني أمية. هذا الرجل أعماله مفقودة
مثل عندنا «سيف بن عمر التميمي» مؤرخ
ليس برجل دين، بل أنه رجل قبيلة أكثر من كونه رجل دين
معظم أعمال هذا الرجل مفقودة
لم يتبقَ منها إلا جزء وليس مكتمل
جزء من كتاب «الفتوح وأخبار الجمل وصفين»
كثير من هذه المرويات أو هذه الأعمال المفقودة
احتواها «الطبري» في كتابه
«الطبري» قد يُعد أفضل من طبّق فكرة التاريخ البشري
أنني أجمع أخبار كل الأمم وكل الدول في كتاب واحد
وأحقّب لها، لكن بناءً على التصور الإسلامي للتاريخ
إذا نتكلم عن التاريخ البشري
فيه برضه الجزئية اللي لها علاقة بالتاريخ
إذا المسلمين أرّخوا تاريخهم
وحتى مثلًا في الفتوحات الإسلامية فيه «حسام عيتاني»
كان يقول أن المسلمين أهملوا تاريخ الأمم المغلوبة
وهي الأمم اللي هُزمت مقابل المسلمين
وأن هذا أثّر على التاريخ الإسلامي سلبًا
ليش أُهمل تدوين تاريخ الأمم المغلوبة عند المسلمين؟
إذا هو يقصد الفترة المعاصرة في حركة التدوين التاريخي
هو معظم التوجه في المدارس الموجودة اليوم
أو إلى وقت قريب، نقول في المئة سنة الأخيرة
في المدارس الأكاديمية إن صح التعبير
كان الاعتماد التراث التاريخي الإسلامي
بكون أن هو الأكثر تداولًا والموجود لدينا
واللي سهل الوصول إليه
لأنه مطبوع ومنشور، فبالتالي أنت كباحث
بإمكانك تروح أي مكتبة وتحصل على هذه المصادر
لكن مثلًا تواريخ الأمم المغلوبة، كثير منها ظل غير مترجم إلى العربية
بس هل العرب ما دونوا تلك الحقبة، تلك الفترة؟
شوف، لما ترجع للماضي يوجد استثناءات
هناك مؤرخين مسلمين نقلوا عن مؤرخين غير مسلمين
على سبيل المثال «محمد بن جرير الطبري» بالمناسبة هو ليس عربي
هو ليس عربي في جذوره، لكن في هويته وفي تكوينه عربي مسلم
لكن «الطبري» كان مهتم بتاريخ الفرس
فكثير من أخبار الإمبراطورية الفارسية الساسانية
استقاها من كتاب «سير ملوك العجم»
«خذاينامه» هذا قد يكون أندر مصدر تاريخي فارسي
أُلف باللغة «البهلوية»
عبارة عن حولية. لا يوجد لها شخص محدد يكتبها
حولية ملكية، تدون أخبار البلاط الفارسي
حتى سقوط هذه الإمبراطورية
هذا الكتاب تُرجم، ترجمه «عبدالله بن المقفع»
«عبدالله بن المقفع» رجل فارسي معتز بقوميته
أُتهم بعنصريته أو بما يسمى وقتها بالشعوبية
أي تعصبه للقومية الفارسية
لكنه ترجم هذا الكتاب إلى اللغة العربية
قيل أن «الطبري» نقل عنه أخبار كثير من الفرس
عندنا مؤرخ أو أنموذج آخر «علي بن الحسن المسعودي»
هذا من أهم المؤرخين وأذكى المؤرخين اللي دونوا التاريخ
هو رحالة ومؤرخ وجغرافي
اعتمد على كثير من المصادر اليونانية والسريانية
في كتاباته، مثلًا في «مروج الذهب ومعادن الجوهر»
في «التنبيه والاشراف» في «أخبار الزمان»
«أخبار الزمان» هذا موسوعة تاريخية فُقدت، ما باقي منها إلا جزء واحد
لكن في الكتابين هذه «تنبيه والاشراف» و«مروج الذهب»
اعتمد على مؤرخين يونان وسريان، ونقل عنهم
فهذا يعتبر استثناء
الحين ودي أرجع إلى ما قبل البعثة النبوية
ودي أتخيل شكل شبه الجزيرة العربية
كيف كانت؟ أيش كان المحيط اللي حولها؟
أيش كانت الأمم والإمبراطوريات اللي تحيط بها؟
فلو تعطيني صورة شاملة لما هو...
للوضع السياسي
والحضاري
للدول والأمم المجاورة للجزيرة العربية
خلنا نختصر سؤالك على القرن السادس الميلادي
وصولًا إلى السابع الميلادي
أو الربع الأول من القرن السابع الميلادي اللي ظهرت فيه الدعوة
نتخيل الخارطة السياسية للعالم القديم
والجزيرة العربية تقع في قلب هذا العالم
هناك امبراطوريتين كبريين
في الشرق الإمبراطورية الفارسية الساسنية
والتي كان يحكمها الشاهات الفرس أو ما سميوا بالأكاسرة
وفي الغرب الإمبراطورية الرومانية الشرقية
أو الإمبراطورية البيزنطية أو ما سماها العرب بإمبراطورية الروم
وكانت عاصمتها القسطنطينية
هذه أكبر قوتين عظميين. هاتين القوتين العظميين
كانت لهما محاولة التدخل في الجزيرة العربية
التي كانت وقتها تعيش ما يشبه الفراغ السياسي
كانت توجد كيانات إقليمية صغيرة، جنوب الجزيرة العربية
مثلًا كانت عندنا ممالك «قتبان» «معين» «سبأ»
وصولًا إلى مملكة «حمير» وهي آخر هذه الممالك
مملكة «حمير» كانت تتمدد وتتقلص بحسب قوتها السياسية
وفي ذات الوقت، كانت هناك مملكة اسمها مملكة «كندة»
مملكة «كندة» كانت في فترة من الفترات
تحكم في وسط الجزيرة العربية
وكانت عاصمتها في فترة من الفترات مدينة «الفاو» الأثرية اليوم
لكن أيضًا هاتين المملكتين سقطتا
في فترة مبكرة من القرن السادس الميلادي
مملكة «حمير» تقريبًا سقطت عام 518- 523
في الخمس السنوات هذه سقطت على مستعمر خارجي هم الأحباش
فيما عُرف بقصة «الأخدود» واضطهاد نصارى نجران
وما تبعها من تداعيات سياسية خطيرة
انتهت بالاحتلال الحبشي أو الاثيوبي
لأجزاء واسعة من جنوب الجزيرة العربية
باقي أجزاء الجزيرة العربية، طبعًا شمال الجزيرة العربية
كانت فيها مملكتين: «المناذرة» وعاصمتها «الحيرة» هذه في العراق
«الغساسنة» في بلاد الشام
من كان يحكم «المناذرة»؟
«المناذرة» هم أسرة عربية أزدية من جنوب الجزيرة العربية
ضمن طليعة القبائل العربية اللي استقرت في السواد، في سواد العراق
وأسست مملكة يحكمها «بنو نصر اللخميين»
وكانت عاصمتهم «الحيرة»
وأبناء عمومتهم من «الغساسنة» وهم من الأزد أيضًا
كانوا في الشام
وهاتين الدولتين تبنتا النصرانية كدين رسمي للدولة
لكن كل دولة تبنت النصرانية بحسب مذهبها
المذهب «النسطوري» مذهب الكنيسة الشرقية في مملكة «المناذرة»
المذهب «اليعقوبي» أو مذهب كنيسة «أنطاكيا»
هذا في مملكة «الغساسنة» في غالب الأحوال
في وسط الجزيرة العربية، وفي الجزء الأوسط...
أيش كانت اللغة عندهم الثنين؟
العربية
العربية؟
كانت اللغة العربية هي السائدة. كلغة الشعر، كلغة الثقافة
ما كانوا متأثرين بالإمبراطوريات اللي هم تابعين لها؟
التأثر موجود، سواءً تأثر سياسي أو ديني
لا تنسى أن اللغة السريانية مثلًا سيطرت على الكنيسة
كلغة طقوس، لغة الصلاة، لغة التراتيل
كانت هي اللغة المؤثرة الأكبر سواءً في الشام أو في العراق
أو حتى في الكنائس الموجودة في الجزيرة العربية
وكانت تتبع للكنائس الشرقية
فاللغة السريانية كانت لغة الكنيسة أو لغة الكنائس الأوسع
إلى جانب اللغة اليونانية. وهذه بنأتي عليها
لكن الجزيرة العربية حتى لما استكمل حديثنا عن الوضع السياسي
كانت تعيش فراغ سياسي
الجزء الأكبر من الجزيرة العربية كان يعيش تحت الحكم القبلي
حكم القبيلة هو السائد
ودي أعرف الحين الفرس والروم في هذه الفترة
كيف كان ينظروا للجزيرة العربية؟
أيش كانت نظرته اتجاههم؟ هل كانوا يبغون يحتلونها؟
هل كانوا ينظرون لها بأنها مكان غير مهم ومهمل؟ أيش كانوا يشوفون؟
هي كانت نظرة دونية للعرب
لما تستقرأ خطاب كسرى في رده على رسالة النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ستجد فيه كمية من العنجهية، من الغطرسة
من النظرة الدونية المحتقرة للعرب
هذه النظرة هي جزء من السياق الثقافي السائد في الإمبراطوريتين
التي كانتا تعيشا فترة استقرار وتحضّر
هم ينظرون للعرب مثل نظرتهم لكثير من الأمم المتخلفة
الأمم التي لا يحكمها نظام سياسي
ولا نظام حضاري، ولا حتى نظام ديني
فكان هذا هو منظارهم الأساسي
واللي بنوا عليه حتى تصورهم لسكان الجزيرة العربية
لكن بيئة الجزيرة العربية الصحراوية القاحلة
جعلت من الصعوبة أن ينظروا لها كمنطقة تستحق
أن يوجهوا لها مقدراتهم العسكرية أو البشرية لإحتلالها
لأن الثمن مكلف للغاية
طبعًا هناك محاولات بالمناسبة لاحتلال الجزيرة العربية
مِن مَن؟
على سبيل المثال، في عام 24 قبل الميلاد
في القرن الأول قبل الميلاد، أرسل الرومان حملة عسكرية ضخمة
للسيطرة على طرق التجارة في بلاد العربية السعيدة
أو جنوب غرب الجزيرة العربية
هذه الحملة انطلقت من مصر عبر البحر
ونزلت في شمال غرب الجزيرة العربية في منطقة قريبة من...
في «لوكوكوميا» هذا ميناء إلى الآن مختلف فيه
أين يقع «لوكوكوميا» إلى الآن اختلف فيه المؤرخين
الدكتور «سليمان الذييب» كتب كتاب جميل ومهم عن هذه الحملة
هذه الحملة انطلقت ووصلت عبر الطريق البري الصحراوي إلى نجران
من نجران انطلقت إلى «الجوف» في اليمن
ووصلت إلى حدود «مأرب» وحاصرتها
لكنها انتهت إلى الفشل وإلى الهزيمة
طبعًا سبب فشل هذه الحملة في غالبها
هو سبب جغرافي، ليس سبب عسكري
كثير من الجنود ماتوا بسبب العطش
بسبب الجوع، بسبب الظروف المناخية القاسية
لأنهم ما كانوا متعودين على المناخ الصحراوي
فانتهت هذه الحملة بالفشل
فلما وصلوا إلى قناعة أن الرومان
على عظمة جيوشهم وقوتهم العسكرية؛ ما استطاعت فشلت
الفرس كانت لهم محاولاتهم
«سابور» الأول تقريبًا، إذا لم تخني الذاكرة
قاد حملة عسكرية وصل بها إلى شرق الجزيرة العربية
ضد قبيلة «بني تميم» وانطلق حتى وصل إلى حدود نجد
وطبعًا كانت الحملة في هدفها الرئيسي
محاولة تأديب بعض القبائل العربية
التي استولت على بعض القوافل التجارية الفارسية
لكنه في الأخير، لم يستطع أن يفرض سيطرته
السياسية أو العسكرية على هذه الأقاليم؛ فاضطروا للانسحاب
فيه محاولات، لكن في الأخير هي لم تجد النجاح
كيف كان ينظر العرب لهذه الإمبراطوريتين؟
نظرة العرب هي في الأخير
هذه الإمبراطوريتين على أنها دول متقدمة، دول متحضرة
ولكن أخلاقيًّا كان هناك عدم قبول
لبعض الثقافات الموجودة في الإمبراطوريتين
لأن العرب لهم موروثهم الأخلاقي
لهم موروثهم الحضاري حتى قبل الإسلام
أتكلم عن الموروث الأخلاقي
فيه هنا «حسام عيتاني» كان يقول
أن الإمبراطوريتين البيزنطية والفارسية
كان لها نفوذ على الحبشة واليمن
وجنوب شبه الجزيرة العربية عمومًا، وأطراف شمالها
ودي أعرف ليش هذه الأماكن اختاروها؟
جنوب الجزيرة العربية منطقة مهمة من الناحية الاقتصادية
لأنها تقع في عنق طرق التجارة
وبالتالي، قوافل تجارة البخور، التوابل، تمر عبر هذه المناطق
إضافةً إلى المناطق غنية اقتصاديًّا
وتصل هذه القوافل أو هذه البضائع بأسعار كبيرة
إلى مصر، إلى الشام، إلى الأقاليم اللي تتبع للإمبراطورية البيزنطية
الإمبراطورية البيزنطية كانت على علاقة جيدة
مع مملكة «تكسوب» أو الحبشة
وخاصةً في الجانب الديني، وعلاقة الكنائس مع بعضها كانت جيدة
الذي حدث حتى أسرد لك السياق
النصرانية وجدت سبيل إلى جنوب الجزيرة العربية
إلى بعض مناطق جنوب الجزيرة العربية، شرق الجزيرة العربية
وكانت هناك محاولات مبكرة لنشر النصرانية
تبنتها الدولة نفسها، تبنتها الدولة البيزنطية
وفي قراءات كثير من المؤرخين، و هذا لا يبعد عن الحقيقة
أن النصرانية أو الدين كانت محاولة لبسط النفوذ
تعرف منذ القرن الثالث، القرن الرابع؛ تتابعت بعثات التنصير
أو ما كان يسمونها هم بالبعثات التبشيرية
لكن سميت حملات تنصيرية
اللي وصلت إلى مملكة «حمير» وصلت إلى «ظفار»
ووصلت إلى منطقة أهم من هذه كلها؛ نجران
وفي نجران بدأت النصرانية تجد قبول
وبدأت تتوسع، بدأت تنتشر بين كثير من المجتمع
في وقت بدأت اليهودية تبرز في البلاط الحميري
أو البلاط الحميري بدأ يتبنى اليهودية كدين مضاد
لدين الإمبراطورية البيزنطية وهو النصرانية
بدأ الوضع يتوتر
لذلك احنا نسمع الحادثة التي خلّدها القرآن بحادثة «الأخدود»
الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول
«قُتِلَ أصْحابُ الأُخْدُودِ. النّارِ ذاتِ الوَقُودِ. إذْ هم عَلَيْها قُعُودٌ»
حدثت «الأخدود» ما الذي حدث بالضبط؟
آخر ملوك «حمير» اسمه «يوسف أسار»
أو من أسمته المصادر العربية «يوسف بن شرحبيل، ذو نواس»
هذا الرجل تبنى اليهودية ووجد في تمدد النصرانية
إلى نجران، إلى ظفار، إلى عدن؛ تهديد لكيانه السياسي
فبالتالي قرر أن يبادر إلى محاولة اجتثاث هذا التهديد
فشن حملات عسكرية على الكنائس النصرانية في ظفار وعدن
ثم اتجه إلى الوجود النصراني الأكبر، إلى نجران
وحاصر المدينة عدة أشهر. استطاع أن يقتحم المدينة
أنا لن أدخل في التفاصيل، لكن كل المصادر
الإسلامية، اليونانية، السريانية، الحبشية
كل المصادر اللي أرّخت، حتى النقوش
تؤكد على أنه ارتكب مجزرة كبيرة
قتل كثير من أتباع الطائفة النصرانية في المنطقة
وحاول أن يجتث النصرانية. أيضًا هدم الكنائس وحرقها
وقتل كثير من الناس حرقًا أو صبرًا كما يقولون
صبرًا يعني إعدام. وحرقًا حفر لهم الأخاديد وقتلهم
هذه الحادثة كانت لها تداعيات
لأن كثير من اللي نجوا من الحادثة اتجهوا للحبشة
اتجهوا للحيرة في العراق، اتجهوا لبلاد الشام
نقلوا أخبار ما حدث لهم
فالحادثة كان لها أصدائها الكبيرة جدًّا في الكنائس النصرانية
في القسطنطينية، في أنطاكيا، في الإسكندرية، في الحيرة، في المدائن
وصلت الأخبار، وبالتالي أصبح هناك توتر ديني
وصل إلى الإمبراطور «جستنيان»
الذي تقول الرواية الإسلامية ملك الروم
أنه أرسل رسالة إلى نجاشي الحبشة يطلب منه أن يُعين أبناء ملته
وهذا الكلام ماهو بعيد من الحقيقة
رغم اختلاف التفاصيل والأشخاص
ما بين المصادر الإسلامية والنصرانية
لكن الذي حدث أن نجاشي الحبشة
الذي أسمته المصادر النصرانية بالملك «كالب»
هذا الرجل أعد حملة عسكرية كبيرة عبر البحر الأحمر
نزل في «المخا» خاض معركة كبيرة جدًّا
مع «يوسف ذو نواس» انتصر، قتل «يوسف ذو نواس» في المعركة
«كالب الأصبحة» وهو اسم الملك الحبشي الإثيوبي
اقتحم جنوب الجزيرة العربية حتى وصل إلى نجران
طبعًا المصادر الإسلامية لا تذكر أنه وصل الي نجران
لكن المصادر اليونانية والسريانية تقول أنه وصل إلى نجران
ليه الاختلاف هذا؟
بسبب المصادر. كل مؤرّخ بالمناسبة له مصادر
فيه تباين حتى في أسماء من نشروا النصرانية نفسها
مثلًا الرواية الإسلامية تقول
أن الذي نشر النصرانية في نجران هو شخص اسمه «فيمن»
و«فيمن» تلقاها الرجل عنه اسمه «عبدالله بن الثامر»
وأنه نشر النصرانية
المصادر السريانية واليونانية تقول أن الشخص اسمه...
أو كل وحدة معليش فيه تباين بينها
لكن مثلًا الرواية النسطورية السريانية تقول
أن شخص اسمه «حيان التاجر»
الرواية اليونانية والسريانية تقول أن «كالب الأصبحة» وصل إلى نجران
أقام فيها عدة أشهر. أعاد ترميم وبناء الكنائس
وأعاد تنظيم الأمور الكنسية
جلب معه مجموعة من رجال الدين ورجال الكنائس
عيّن «إكليروس» متكامل للكنيسة
أصبحت الكنيسة بمفهومها العقدي أو المذهبي
الكنيسة النجرانية تابعة لكنيسة الحبشة
التي تبنت مذهب مختلف حتى عن مذهب الإمبراطورية البيزنطية
مذهب «الطبيعة الواحدة»
أو المذهب «اليعقوبي» لاحقًّا الذي يعرف بهذا الاسم
طبعًا هو انسحب وعاد إلى بلاده الحبشة
ظل النفوذ الحبشي موجود في جنوب الجزيرة العربية
لكنه ظل متقلّص في المدن هذه أو الحواضر
بل أن النجران مع المرور الزمن أصبحت مستقلة سياسيًا، دينيًّا، عسكريًّا
أصبحت أشبه ما تكون بإقليم مستقل
ليش أعطيتها الأهمية؟
لأنها مثّلت أكبر مركز للنصرانية في جنوب الجزيرة العربية
تجد الحين الكثير من المصادر اليونانية أو السريانية
اللي تناولت حواضر الجزيرة العربية، مدن الجزيرة العربية
بعطيك سبيل المثال مؤرخ وجغرافي
اسمه «بطليموس» يوناني، في القرن الثاني الميلادي
هذا الرجل له كتاب اسمه «الجغرافيا»
دوّن فيه أهم المدن الواقعة على طريق تجارة البخور
فذكر يثرب، هي المدينة المنورة «يثربو»
ذكر نجران باسم نجرانا أو «نجرانا متروبلس»
وواصل جرد هذه المدن
المؤرخين مؤرخي الكنائس نظروا إلى نجران
على أنها أهم مركز للنصرانية في جنوب جزيرة العربية
وهذا السبب لاهتمامهم بها
من ناحية انتشار النصرانيين، من ناحية تركّز وجودها
من ناحية حتى علاقة الطائفة النصرانية بالمنطقة
بالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان لها اهتمامه في المصادر الإسلامية والمصادر النصرانية
كيف تحولت من أهم مركز للنصارى إلى مكان اضطهد فيه النصارى؟
مثل ما ذكرت لك، أن «ذو نواس»
نظر إلى تواجد النصرانية وانتشارها في نجران
على أنه خطر يهدد دولته، واستقلال دولته
وأن هذا الخطر يمثّل وجود بيزنطة
لأن الدولة البيزنطية والإمبراطورية البيزنطية دعمت هذا التواجد
من خلال ارسال القساوسة والرهبان
استضافت كثير من رجال الكنائس النجرانية
كانت هناك علاقات دينية كنسية متواصلة
طيب هذا بالنسبة لجنوب الجزيرة العربية، شرقها؟
وهل أقرب للفرس؟
شرق الجزيرة العربية أو ما عُرف في التاريخ الإسلامي
باسم إقليم «البحرين الكبرى»
في بعض الفترات خضعت للنفوذ الفارسي
وكانت هناك محاولات فارسية للهيمنة عليها
لكنها غالبًا كانت تعيش استقلال سياسي تحت منظومة قبلية
لكن ستجد أن مثلما المجوسية وجدت لها بعض الإقبال
النصرانية النسطورية وجدت انتشار أكبر
بين قبائل «بنو عبد القيس» بين قبائل «بنو تميم»
أيش النسطورية؟
النسطروية مذهب الكنيسة الشرقية النصرانية
الذي انتشر في بلاد الرافدين
جزء من الكنائس النسطورية في الهضبة الإيرانية
وصولًا إلى شرق الجزيرة العربية
والنسطورنية على خلاف عميق مع الكنيسة الغربية
اليوم نسمع بالكلدان النصارى في العراق
هم أحفاد هذه المدرسة. ويؤمنون بطبيعتين للسيد المسيح عليه السلام
الطبيعة البشرية والطبيعة الإلهية
احنا ما ودنا ندخل في التفاصيل اللاهوتية
لكن خلنا نتحدث عن التاريخ
النسطورية وجدت انتشار في شرق الجزيرة العربية، وجدت إقبال
بل إن الكشوفات الأثرية مؤخرًا
أثبتت أن النسطورية كان لها وجود مهم ومعتبر في شرق الجزيرة العربية
أيش طبيعته؟
كنائس، أديرة، صلبان، كلها موجودة
أنا بعطيك نص تاريخي يؤكد على هذه الحقيقة
أن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم حينما استقبل وفد «بنو عبد القيس»
وكان فيهم «الجارود بن المعلّى» هذا الرجل كان على النصرانية
جزء من أعضاء هذا الوفد وفد «بنو عبد القيس»
كانوا نصارى نساطرة على الأرجح
فهذا النص الإسلامي يؤكد على أن النصرانية
كانت موجودة في شرق الجزيرة
بالنسبة لغرب الجزيرة العربية وحتى وسطها
ليش كان فيه غياب لهذا التواجد في هذه المنطقتين؟
النصرانية؟
النصرانية إيه، سواءً من بيزنطة أو من...
خلنا نقرأ الخريطة الدينية للجزيرة العربية
الوثنية هي دين الأغلبية
أنا لما أتكلم عن النصرانية وعن اليهودية؛ فهي دين الأقلية
أو ديانة طارئة. هي جاءت في فترة معينة، وانتهت في فترة معينة
مثلًا النصرانية في نجران أو في جنوب الجزيرة العربية
بدأت من القرن الرابع أو الخامس الميلادي
انتهت بعد ظهور الإسلام بعدة قرون
وذات الشيء ينطبق على شرق الجزيرة العربية
ذات الشيء ينطبق على يثرب أو على المدينة منورة
أنا ذكرت لك أن الوثنية هي دين الأغلبية
لكن ستجد أن هناك أتباع لليهودية، أتباع للنصرانية، أتباع للمجوسية
هناك تنوع ديني، أو ما أسميته لك قبل شوي فوضى دينية
ما في ديانة رسمية، لأن ما في كيان سياسي أصلًا يوحّد هذه الأجزاء
مثلًا لو أتينا على وسط الجزيرة العربية
أهم قبيلة في هذا الإقليم المهم، هم قبيلة «بنو حنيفة»
أهم وأغنى وأكبر قبيلة
وجدت النصرانية لها طريق بين أبناء هذه القبيلة
مثلًا ملك اليمامة «هوذة بن علي الحنفي» كان على النصرانية
بل إن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم أرسل إليه يدعوه للإسلام
طبعًا هو رد رد سلبي، أن لا بأس لدي من أن أعتنق دينك أو أن أتبعك
لكن مقابل أن تشاركني في هذا الأمر، في أمر الرسالة
فالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم رفض هذا الأمر
طبعًا لم يمضي السنوات إلا وهلك «هوذة بن علي الحنفي»
فالنصرانية كان لها أيضًا وجود في وسط الجزيرة العربية
لما ننتقل إلى غرب الجزيرة العربية إلى أهم ثلاث حواضر
مكة، يثرب، ثم الطائف
لكن احنا نركز على مكة ويثرب
لأن المصادر التاريخية تساعدنا على قراءة التاريخ الديني
في يثرب اليهودية لها وجود
متمثل بالثلاث القبائل: «بني قريضة» «بني النضير» «بني قينقاع»
وهناك ما بسميه إجماع تاريخي، لكن هناك سرد تاريخي واضح
أن هذه القبائل قدمت من بلاد الشام
بعد اضطهاد الإمبراطور الروماني «هادريان» لليهود
وطردهم من فلسطين
أن فيه ثلاث قبائل يهودية استقرت في يثرب
في نهاية القرن الأول وبداية القرن الثاني الميلادي
وأن هذه القبائل حاولت أن تستقر يثرب
وبدأت نشاط اقتصادي مهم
وكانت تمثل ثقل سياسي واقتصادي وديني مهم
عند هجرة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
مقابل هجرة قبائل عربية قدمت من جنوب الجزيرة العربية
بعد انهيار سد «مأرب»
و هما قبيلتها «الأوس» و«الخزرج»
وهما من عُرفا في التاريخ الإسلامي باسم الأنصار
في البداية حدث صراع بين اليهود وبين الوافد الجديد
من هؤلاء القبائل العربية
لكن هذا الصراع انتهى بانتصار الأوس والخزرج واستقرارهم في يثرب
ويثرب كانت عبارة عن واحة زراعية خصبة
غنية بالمياه وغنية بالتربة الخصبة. وتقع على طرق القوافل
وكان لليهودية وجود محدود، عبارة عن تجار وعن أشخاص
أيش كانت لغتهم؟
العربية، مثل ماهو الحال في مكة
في مكة كان للنصرانية وجود ممثل في أشخاص
في تجار في المقام الأول
أو في ما نسميهم احنا ملك اليمين أو الرقيق، إذا صح التعبير
لأن كان كثير من الرقيق الذين يعملون في خدمة تجار «قريش»
بعضهم كانوا نصارى من أصول غير عربية
ولذلك أشار تقريبًا «الأزرقي» في «أخبار مكة»
إلى ما سمي بمقبرة النصارى
أيش اللي حصل؟
مقبرة خاصة بالنصارى
لكن نرجع ونقول أن هذا الوجود هو وجود طارئ، ليس وجود أصيل
كيف كان ينظرون الآخرين لمكة؟
هل كان لها اعتبار؟ هل كان لها قيمة؟
الكعبة، هل كان لها اهتمام؟
هو الحقيقة أن مكة والكعبة المشرفة حضيت بتقدير بإجماع عند العرب
أن هذا بيت إبراهيم وأنه حرم الله، وأن له قدسيته، وأن له مكانته
فبالتالي حتى «قريش» أخذت مكانتها بين القبائل العربية من هذا السياق
سياق أن هذا بيت الله، وأن هذا بيت بناه إبراهيم
وأن سنويًّا كل قبائل العرب تجتمع لأداء فريضة الحج
فبالتالي هذا حرم الله
حتى كثير من الحروب والصراعات عندما حدثت
مثل حروب «الفجار» سُميت لأيش؟ لأنهم فجروا في حرم الله
الصراع بين القبائل العربية هذه
لكنها كانت في الإجمال هي نظرة تقدير، نظرة تبجيل
نظرة احترام لقدسية المكان
هذا عند العرب؟
عند العرب
عند غير العرب؟ أو عند الفرس والروم هل كانوا ينظروا لها...؟
عند الفرس والروم، خلنا نقول فيه تدوينات المؤرخين النصارى المتأخرين
هناك سياق مختلف
وهناك سياق يعترف بأن الكعبة هي بيت الله
الذي بناه إبراهيم وابنه إسماعيل
متى بدأت الإشارة لمكة؟
مصدر نسطوري سرياني في القرن السابع الميلادي
هذا المصدر أشار إلى الكعبة المشرفة باسم «قبة إبراهيم»
هذا أول مرة يشار الكعبة؟
أول مرة يشار للكعبة في مصدر نصراني معاصر للإسلام
لكن مكة أصلًا هي سؤال مهم عند المستشرقين
والسبب في ذلك، أنه لا توجد كثير من الإشارات الواضحة للبيت الحرام
في كتابات المؤرخين الكلاسيكيين
أيش سبب الغياب هذا؟
هناك أسباب كثيرة كانت محط اهتمام
كثير من المؤرخين وكثير من الباحثين
رغم أن فيه إشارة مثلًا عند «بطليموس»
«بطليموس» جغرافي أشار إلى الطرق الواقعة على طريق التجارة
فذكر «يثربو» «مكروبا» «نجرانا»
«مكروبا» الأرجح أن هي مكة
لكن بالنطق اليوناني ما قالك مكة قال «مكروبا»
مثلًا فيه مؤرخ كلاسيكي «ديودور الصقلي»
أشار إلى أن هناك حرم أو بيت مقدس
بيت رباعي الزوايا أو بيت رباعي الشكل
مقدس، يقدسه سكان الجزيرة العربية، كما أسماه
فهذه إشارة غير مباشرة
لكن ما كانت في نظر كثير من أتباع المدرسة التنقيحية، إشارات كافية
إلى أن هناك كعبة مشرفة، وأن هذه الكعبة المشرفة موجودة
أو بناها إبراهيم عليه السلام
وأنها موجودة قبل الإسلام بآلاف السنين
فهذا كان سؤال مهم. وسؤال وجد كثير من النقاش
ووجد كثير من الخلاف عند المؤرخين العرب
مثلًا فيه كتاب اسمه «تجارة مكة» خرج منتصف الثمانينات
لمؤرخة دينماركية بريطانية اسمها «باتريشا كرون»
تكلمت عن تجارة مكة، وعن قصة الإيلاف
وكان لها أطروحتها، هذا على لسانها
أننا لم نجد في المصادر اليونانية، القبطية
السريانية، الكلاسيكية بشكل عام
ما يؤكد على أن هناك شيء اسمه مكة بمنظورها عند العرب
ما يؤكد أن هناك تجارة إيلاف مارستها قبيلة «قريش»
ما بين اليمن، ما بين الشام، ما بين العراق
الأرجح طبعًا هذا تصورها أو حسب مزاعمها
أن مكة الحقيقية تقع في منطقة قريبة من «البتراء»
مستندة على بعض المزاعم التي تتكلم عن معبد وثني كبير
في جنوب غرب «البتراء» تقريبًا قريبًا من تبوك
طبعًا هذه الأطروحة وجدت الرفض ما بين الباحثين الغربيين أنفسهم
والسبب في ذلك كما يقول «روبرت سيرجنت»
من السذاجة يا «باتريشا كرون» أن نحكم على السياق
اللي ذكرتيه وفق منظورك، لكن لو قرأنا المصادر التاريخية
وفهمنا العقلية العربية. فهمناه في التدوين، في التاريخ
في خلفيتها الدينية، التاريخية، الحضارية
الكلام هذا لا يمكن أن ينطبق على أرض الواقع
الإشارة الأهم، قبل المصادر الكلاسيكية والمصادر السريانية واليونانية
هناك ما ورد في العهد القديم
وتحديدًا في سفر «التكوين»
عن الإشارة إلى أن الله سبحانه وتعالى لنبيه إبراهيم
أن الله سيبارك في ابنك إسماعيل، وسيجعل من ذريته أمة كبيرة
وأن هذه الأمة سيكون لها شأنها
وفي موضع آخر من العهد القديم وفي سفر «التكوين»
تجي الإشارة إلى وادي بكاء أو وادي بكة
بكة طبعًا، أيش الإشكالية هنا؟
الإشكالية أن نصوص العهد القديم وصلت إلينا بأكثر من نسخة
لذلك هناك خلاف في المصطلحات
لو تقرأ النسخة الإنجليزية المعيارية المعتمدة
للعهد القديم الكتاب المقدس، ستجد وادي بكة
بينما لو تقرأ النسخة العربية، ستجد مثلًا إشارة إلى وادي البكاء
فرق بين بكة والبكاء
هنا الإشكالية التي تواجه الباحث
أن هناك تباين في ما يرد، أو في نسخة العهد القديم
العهد القديم؛ الكتاب المقدس
الحديث عن إبراهيم وإسماعيل
في التسميات اللي كان يطلقونها الآخرين على العرب
ففيه ناس كانوا يسمونهم الإسماعيليون أو الهاجريون أو الطائيون
ودي تعطيني من اللي أطلق هذه الأسماء، اختلاف الأسماء؟
لو تلاحظ أن أغلبهم ما أحد ذكر تسمية العرب عن العرب
فمتى ظهرت هذه التسمية؟
شوف، احنا لو أردنا أن نفهم السياق الكامل لهذه التسميات
يجب أن نفهم التصور النصراني المبكر
عن سكان الجزيرة العربية، عن الجزيرة العربية نفسها
مثلًا هم أطلقوا عليها عدة مسميات
نبدأ بالكلاسيكيين، أو المؤرخيين الكلاسيكيين الوثنيين، ما قبل النصارى
وصولًا إلى مؤرخي الكنيسة أو المؤرخين الكنسيين
قسموا الجزيرة العربية إلى ثلاثة أقسام
العربية الصخرية، ويشمل غرب الجزيرة العربية وصولًا إلى «البتراء»
العربية الصحراوية، أي المناطق الرملية
والعربية السعيدة أو العربية المباركة
طبعًا العربية السعيدة هذه أُطلقت في الأصل
على جنوب الجزيرة العربية
لكنها امتدت مع المؤرخين النصارى لاحقًّا
إلى أن أصبحت تشمل مكة، تشمل يثرب، تشمل غرب الجزيرة العربية
فالفهم النصراني المبكر للجزيرة العربية وللعرب أو للسكان
انطلق من تصورات...
معليش، العربية السعيدة فيه سبب للتسمية؟
أحد أسباب تسميتها غناها الاقتصادي
لكن التصور النصراني المبكر أو الفهم النصراني للعرب
هو أصلًا مبني على نصوص العهد القديم
وخاصةً الأسفار الأولى من العهد القديم
الخمسة الأولى: سفر «التكوين» سفر «الخروج» «لاوين» «يشوع»
«العدد والتثنية» أو ما سمي بكتاب «التوراة»
ما يعرف عندنا بكتاب «التوراة»
مثل ما ذكرت لك، في أحد نصوص سفر «التكوين»
الإشارة إلى أن الله سبحانه وتعالى سيبارك في إسماعيل بن إبراهيم
وسيبارك في ذريته، وسيجعل منهم أمة كبيرة وأمة ذات شأن
وهذا نص آخر، تجد أيضًا في العهد القديم
أظن حتى في السفر «التكوين»
الإشارة إلى خلاف «هاجر» و«سارة»
والذي بسببه إبراهيم خرج بزوجته الثانية «هاجر»
من بلاد الكنعانيين واتجه بهم إلى الصحراء هي وابنها
وأنه أحلّهم أو أنزلهم في وادٍ غير ذي زرع
هذه موجودة في العهد القديم
ومن هذا المنطلق كانت تصورات المؤرخين أو اللاهوتيين النصارى
منذ وقت مبكر لسكان الجزيرة العربية
سواءً تصورات سلبية أو إيجابية
على أنهم من ذرية إسماعيل بن إبراهيم عليهم السلام
فبدأ المصطلح ينتشر. مثلًا عندنا «جيروم»
هذا «جيروم» أحد علماء أو آباء الكنيسة الأوائل
يسميهم باسم الإسماعيليين مثلًا
عندنا «هادريان الليبي» هذا أحد آباء الكنيسة الإنقليزية
تكلم عن الإسماعيليين
وبهذا يقصد العرب؟
يقصد العرب، وهذا المصطلح أصلًا هو يتمدد ويتقلص
بعض المؤرخين الكنيسيين مثلًا اللي يحاول فهم سكان الجزيرة العربية
يتكلم عن الجزيرة العربية يسكنها عدة شعوب
الكنديين، الحميريين، الإسماعيليين
مثلًا آخرين يشيرون إلى الإسماعيلين أو الهاجريين على سبيل التعميم
هاذين المصطلحين هم ما سميا بالمصطلحات التوراتية
لأنهم انطلقا من خلال تصورات أو نصوص العهد القديم
الهاجريين نسبة إلى هاجر عليها السلام
الإسماعيليين نسبة إلى إسماعيل بن إبراهيم عليهم السلام
وكذلك المعديين هذا المصطلح مرتبط أصلًا بإسماعيل
«معد بن عدنان» إلى أن وصل إلى إسماعيل عليه السلام
المصطلحات اتسعت لاحقًّا مع التقادم الزمني
إلى أن ظهر مصطلح الطائيين أو «بنو طيء»
نسبةً إلى القبيلة العربية التي كانت تتمدد في شمال جزيرها العربية
شمالها الشرقي وشمالها الغربي. وكان لها نفوذها الكبير
وستجد أن استخدام هذه المصطلحات، بدأ يتسع على سبيل التعميم
مثلًا معركة «اليرموك» قد مرت عليك معركة «اليرموك»
حينما يأتي مؤرخ أرمني مثل «سيبيوس» أو مؤرخ سرياني
يتكلم عن معركة «اليرموك» يأتي النص
وفي هذا العام من عام 947 سلوقي أو يوناني، حسب التقويم اليوناني
انتصر طائيوا محمد أو الطائيين على الروم في معركة «الجابية»
هذه المصطلحات غير موجودة في الرواية الإسلامية
لكنك لو اسقطها على الواقع اللغوي، الجغرافي، السياسي
ستجد أن الطائيين هم العرب المسلمين
«الجابية» هي نفسها معركة «اليرموك»
حتى استخدام التقويم، ستجد أنهم أيضًا يختلفون عنه
لكن استخدام المصطلح بدأ يتطور
المؤرخين السريان كانوا يستخدمون أكثر
مصطلح الطائيين، مصطلح الهاجريين
ومصطلح الإسماعيليين كان منتشر عند سريان الشرق أو النساطرة
عندنا مؤرخ نسطوري تكلم عن انتصار الإسماعيليين على الفرس
ما يقولك العرب، يقولك الإسماعيليين على الفرس
وأن الله سبحانه وتعالى قد وعد بانتصارهم
وأن هذا ما ورد في العهد القديم وأنها مشيئة الله
المؤرخين اليونان، سواءً اليونان الكلاسيكيين أو اليونان البيزنطيين
ما كانوا يقولون غالبًا، هم يعترفون أنهم من ذرية إسماعيل بن إبراهيم
ولكنهم كانوا يسمونهم اسم مختلف عن هذه المصطلحات
وهم «السراقنة»
هم يعترفون أنهم إسماعيليين، وحتى مصطلح إسماعيلي موجود
لكن المصطلح الأشمل أو مصطلح الأكثر تداولًا
هو «السراقنة» أو «السراسنة» أو «السراكنوس»
وهذا مصطلح موجود حتى منذ عهد المؤرخين الكلاسيكيين
نسبةً إلى؟
مختلف في أصله
وإن كان الأرجح أنه نسبة إلى «سارة» زوجة إبراهيم الأولى
منها تجذّر هذا الاسم
طبعًا هناك رأي، يقول أن هذا الاسم اشتق من قبيلة عربية
سكنت في «سيناء» اسمهم «السوارقة»
لكن فيه خلاف كبير حول هذا الاسم من أين ظهر
لكنه كان منتشر إلى العصور الوسطى عند المؤرخين الأوربيين
حتى لما يتكلمون مثلًا عن انتصارات
خاصة نتكلم عن المصادر اللاتينية في الغرب الأوربي
عندما تتكلم عن فتوحات بلاد الشام
وعن انتصارات العرب في الشام وفي مصر
وعن فتوحات الأندلس، وعن معارك العرب مع الإمبراطورية البيزنطية
يتكلمون عن انتصار «السراقنة» على الروم
حتى في ذلك الوقت؟
إيه، نعم
على سبيل المثال، هناك مؤرخ إنقليزي اسمه «بيدا المبجل»
«بيدا المبجل» عاصر الدولة الأموية
يتكلم في حولياته. هو عنده كتابين
«التاريخ الكنسي للأمة الإنقليزية» و «تفسير الكتاب المقدس»
وفي الكتابين هاذين دوّن نصوص مهمة
تخيل في إنقلترا و في آخر الدنيا؛ ويتكلم عن الفتوحات!
وفي هذا المصدر يقول
وفي هذا الزمان سيطر «السراقنة» من أحفاد إسماعيل
على بلاد «قرطاجنة»
«قرطاجنة» التي نسميها اليوم تونس أو شمال أفريقيا
وأنهم شرٌ مستطير بدأ ينشر الخراب، وينشر الدمار وقتل الناس
هذا تصوّره هو
مؤرخ آخر عاش في فرنسا، له كتاب اسمه «فريدقار»
«فريدقار» هذا حولية لاتينية تكلمت مثلًا عن...
لما تقول حولية تقصد أيش؟
حولية يعني تاريخ، بس أُلفت حسب التاريخ الحولي نسميه
بتسلسل السنين، فلذلك يسمونه الحوليات
«تاريخ فريدقار» أُلّف في فرنسا
تكلم عن معارك فتوحات الشام، عن فتح مصر، عن فتح الأندلس
وهو في آخر الدنيا في فرنسا أو ما يسمّي وقتها ببلاد «غالة»
فمصطلح «السراقنة» كان أيضًا كان موجود
ومتداول عند المؤرخين الأوربيين
وكان تصورهم أن هذه الانتصارات
لا تخرج عن سياق ما ورد في العهد القديم
أن هذه نبوءة، وأن هذه النبوءة بانتصار هؤلاء الناس
اللي خرجوا من الجزيرة العربية؛ تتحقق اليوم
في ذرية إسماعيل بن إبراهيم
لما تقول أنها نسبةً إلى «سارة» وهذه وحدة من التفاسير
هل فيه اختلاف أن العرب أبناء «سارة» أو أبناء «هاجر»؟
إيه فيه. الاجماع أن إسماعيل بن إبراهيم له ذرية
وأن الذرية هذه في سكنت في الجزيرة العربية
وأنها بدأت تنتشر
ما هناك خلاف في الحقيقة
لكن الخلاف هو في الأصل نفسه، كيف تجذّر المصطلح نفسه، لماذا؟
هناك اجماع مثلًا هاجريين نسبةً إلى «هاجر»
إسماعيليين نسبةً إلى إسماعيل
طائيين نسبةً إلى «طيء» القبيلة العربية
لكن الخلاف في اسم «السراقنة» من أين أتى هذا الاسم؟ فيه خلاف
بالنسبة لمصطلح العرب، متى أصبح مصطلح يستخدم؟
شوف، هذا المصطلح...
هل احنا اللي سمينا بأنفسنا العرب أو الآخر سمّانا؟
هو بدأ ينشأ أصلًا مع التقادم الزمني إذا صح التعبير
ما في سبب معين. أنا ما ودي أعطيك إجابة واضحة
لكن أقدم نص، أنا أتذكر قرأت في كتاب «المفصل في تاريخ العرب»
لـ«جواد علي» نص ناقش هذه المسألة تحديدًا
أشار إلى بعض النقوش «الآشورية»
التي أشارت إلى هذا المصطلح، في القرن السابع أو الثامن قبل الميلاد
واشتق هذا الاسم من مصطلح البادية
العرب رديف للبادية أو لسكان الصحراء
وأن هذا الاسم بدأ يتطور شيئًا فشيئًا حتى أُطلق على هذه الأرض
مصطلح المسلمين؟
مع الإسلام
متى بدأ ذكره عند الآخر، نسبةً للمسلمين؟
هو متأخر وهذه المفارقة
المفارقة أن المؤرخين الكنسيين، أغلبهم ما كانوا يسمونهم مسلمين
كانوا يستخدمون مصطلح مثل ما ذكرت لك، الإسماعيليين أو الهاجريين
لكن حتى في دينهم ما كان يسمونه الإسلام
بعطيك على سبيل المثال، شخصية عملت في البلاط الأموي
اسمه «منصور ابن سرجون» الرومي كما أسموه المؤرخين العرب
أو كما أسمته المصادر النصرانية «يوحنا الدمشقي»
«يوحنا الدمشقي» شخصية نصرانية
عملت في بلاطة الخليفة «معاوية» إلى عهد «عبدالملك بن مروان»
عملت في البلاط الأموي وعاصرت أربع خلفاء
وهو مستعرب، لكن هذا الرجل ألّف كتاب
بعد ما اعتزل العمل السياسي، وترهّب وانتقل إلى حياة الكنيسة
ألّف كتاب اسمه «ينابيع المعرفة» موسوعة لاهوتية
في هذه الموسوعة خصص الجزء الآخر
لمناقشة المِلل والأديان التي عاصرها
فأسمى هذا الجزء بكتاب «الهرطقات» أي البِدع
الهرطقات يعني بِدعة
ثم وصل إلى ما أسماه هو ببدعة الإسماعيليين أو هرطقة الإسماعيليين
ستجد أن في هذا النص أو هذا الفصل الذي خصصه عن الإسلام
لم يتكلم عن الإسلام. لم يسمِّ الإسلام باسمه
أبدًا؟
أبدًا، هو تكلم عن بدعة الإسماعيليين
هو تكلم عن تقديس العرب للحجر الأسود
هو طبعًا يقول في السياق
إذا أنتم تنتقدوننا نحن النصارى في تقديسنا للصليب
فماذا تقولون عن طوافكم حول الكعبة وتقديسكم للحجر الأسود؟
طبعًا هو نص فيه جدلي لاهوتي
لكن له مضامين تاريخية مهمة جدًّا
المصطلح هذا متأخر، يمكن ما ظهر إلا في أواخر العصور الوسطى
وإن كان مصطلح عرب أقدم منه
لكن الإسلام كاسم ظل متأخر
ظهور النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كيف كان ينظرون له؟
هو ما يخرج أيضًا عن هذا السياق
لكنه مسألة يكتنفها الغموض، الاضطراب، والإثارة
كيف الإثارة؟
أقدم نص نصراني أشار إلى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان بعد وفاته بأقل من سنتين
وهذا المصدر هو رسالة في الجدل كُتبت باليونانية
تقريبًا سنة الثالثة عشر للهجرة
كتبها شخص متنصر، هو كان يهودي ثم اعتنق النصرانية
وكتبها في الجدل بين اليهودية والنصرانية
بدأ في كتابتها في فلسطين
ومع وصول المسلمين إلى فلسطين
انتقل إلى «قرطاجنة» أو تونس. و أكمل رسالته
طبعًا الرسالة أغلب نصها نص لاهوتي
لكن ترد فيه رواية تاريخية مهمة جدًّا
في هذه الرواية تحدث شخص اسمه إبراهيم
إبراهيم اليهودي، يقول أنني وصلت إلى مدينة «قيسرية»
مدينة ساحلية في فلسطين
فوجدت الناس يتكلمون عن مقتل «سرجيس»
الضابط البيزنطي على يد «السراقنة»
في تقريبًا يوليو عام 634 أي السنة الثالثة عشر للهجرة
بداية السنة الثالثة عشر للهجرة
وأنه ظهر من بين هؤلاء «السراقنة» نبي يبشّر
وصفه بنبي؟
إيه، نبي يبشّر بظهور المسيح أو الممسوح
وأن هذا النبي يحمل مفاتيح الجنة. ويدعو إلى عبادة رب إبراهيم
تقريبًا حسب الذاكرة، في آخر النص
هو يرفض الاعتراف بالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
لأنه يستغرب كيف لنبيٍّ أن يحمل السيف!
وكان هناك سؤال، هل هذا هو الذي بشّر به المسيح؟
أو هل هذا هو النبي الذي بشّر به الأنبياء الأُول؟
فيرفض الاعتراف به
ستجد الفارق ما بين وفاة الرسول وتدوين هذا المصدر؛ سنتين
ستجد أن هذا الرجل يتكلم عن حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
عن السيد المسيح عليه السلام. عن مفاتيح الجنة
لكنه يقف في الأخير رافضًا للاعتراف بنبوته
بعد هذا المصدر، خرجت عدد من المصادر
السريانية، الأرمانية، اليونانية المبكرة في القرن الأول الهجري
التي أشارت إلى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
في السنة الخامسة عشر للهجرة ظهر مصدر سرياني
هذا المصدر عبارة عن ورقة أو ورقتين حولية قصيرة
وجدت في المكتبة البريطانية. حُقّقت وتُرجمت ونشرت باللغة الإنقليزية
واصطلح على تسميتها باسم مدونة أو جزء في فتوحات العرب
لأي مؤلف المجهول، هذا المؤلف المجهول دوّن مجموعة من الأحداث
بحسب التقويم اليوناني السلوقي
فيقول مثلًا في سنة 947 للإسكندر
انتصر طائيوا محمد على الروم في «الجابية»
وأشار إلى الرسول باسمه المجرد، لكن لم يحدد
بعده بعدة سنوات ظهر مؤرخ سرياني اسمه «توما القس»
«توما القس» أيضًا دوّن نص شبيه له
عن معركة «أجنادين» وليس «اليرموك»
وأن في هذا العام، عام تقريبًا 945 للإسكندر
انتصر الطائيون أو طائيوا محمد على الروم في هذا المكان
وقُتل «يردن» إلى آخر السياق
لكن لم يحدد، هل محمد، نبي؟ رسول؟ زعيم؟ قائد عسكري؟
هو وقف عند الاسم
النظرة إلى هذا المصطلح، تبدأ تتطور منذ عهد الخلافة الراشدة لاحقًّا
تحديدًا من أيام الخليفة «عثمان بن عفان»
حينما ظهر مصدر نسطوري في الشرق، في بلاد الرافدين
هذا المصدر أيضًا اصطلح على تسميته بـ«التاريخ الصغير»
«التاريخ الصغير» ما له عنوان
لكن لما حُقِّق اختير له اسم بسبب المقدمة
أن هذا اسمه «التاريخ الصغير»
هو دوّن في الأصل باللغة السريانية
لكنه ترجم لاحقًّا إلى عدة لغات: الألمانية، الإنقليزية، العربية والفرنسية
في هذا النص يتكلم المؤرخ النسطوري المجهول
عن انتصارات بنو إسماعيل على الفرس
في «القادسية» في «حلوان» في «المدائن» وفي غيرها
وأن كان لهم زعيم اسمه «محمد»
وأن الإسماعيليين هؤلاء خرجوا مثل الذر
هو شبههم بالرمل، قال أنهم خرجوا مثل الرمل
وأن لهم زعيم يدبر أمورهم اسمه «محمد»
فهو وقف عند «محمد» كزعيم يدبر أمورهم
هو لم يعترف ولم يشير للنبي، لكن أشار إلى أنه زعيم للعرب
في العصر الأموي لدينا مؤرخين عاصرا الخليفة «معاوية بن أبي سفيان»
أحدهم أرمني وآخر سرياني
المصدر الأرمني اسمه «تاريخ هرقل»
هذا المصدر نسب إلى أسقف الكنيسة الأرمنية «سيبيوس»
هو يتكلم عن نشأة الإسماعيليين، عن أصل الإسماعيليين
وأنهم ينتسبون إلى إسماعيل بن إبراهيم عليه السلام
وأن ظهر من بينهم رجل اسمه «محمد»
يدعوهم إلى ترك عبادة الأصنام
وإلى عبادة رب إبراهيم والإيمان بأنبياء بني إسرائيل
المؤرخ الأرمني فسّر ظهور النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
حسب السرد التوراتي عنده هو
السرد التوراتي الذي يدعو إلى الإيمان برب إبراهيم
أن هذا الرجل يدعو إلى الإيمان برب إبراهيم
الذي ورد في التوراة أو في العهد القديم
ويدعو إلى الإيمان بأنبياء بني إسرائيل
ويدعو إلى تبجيل السيد المسيح عليه السلام
كان له مؤرخ سرياني آخر معاصر عاش في بلاد الجزيرة
وفي إقليم الجزيرة، في أعالي بلاد الرافدين اسمه «يوحنا بن الفنكي»
«يوحنا بن الفنكي» كان معاصر لـ «معاوية بن أبي سفيان»
في البداية هاجم العرب وهاجم المسلمين
وأنهم نشروا الدمار ونشروا الرعب بين شعوب الأمة النصرانية
ولكن في هذا الزمان، ساد الأمن وساد الأمان
وساد التسامح والتعايش بين كل هذه الشعوب
التي عاشت تحت حكم هذا الرجل «معاوية بن أبي سفيان»
الذي يحكم كل هذه الأقاليم التي كانت تقع تحت حكم
الدولتين الرومانية والفارسية
وأن سبب قوة هذه الأمة وسبب انتصارهم
وخروجهم من بلادهم ومن أرضهم، يقصد الجزيرة العربية
أن خرج من بينهم رجل مرشد وداعي
يدعوهم إلى ترك عبادة الأصنام وعبادة الخالق عز وجل
ويدعوهم إلى التطهر والنظافة والختان
طبعًا الختان هذه عادة غريبة عند النصارى
لذلك ستجدن أن في بعض النصوص
يسمون الإسماعيليين أو العرب بالأمة المختونة أو الإسماعيليين المختونين
الختان موجود في الإسلام وموجود في اليهودية
لكن غير موجود في النصرانية
كممارسة مرتبطة بالدين بالإسلام أو كممارسة الطهارة
فهو كان يدعوهم بالمختونين
وأن هذا الرجل هو من أسس دولتهم، ومن أسس دينهم الجديد
ومؤسس معتقدهم. ومن أسس هذه المنظومة الحضارية والدينية الجديدة
المصطلح يتطور إلى أن نصل إلى القرن الثالث أو الرابع الهجري
إلى أن يعترفون أنه صلى الله عليه وسلم كان رسول
وأنه خرج من بين أمته
وكانت فيه محاولات لربط بعض ممارسات الكنائس النصرانية
بالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
مثلًا عندنا تاريخ دوّن بالعربية اسمه «تاريخ سيرت» أو «تاريخ السيرتية»
يتكلم عن أن فيه وفد نصراني جاء من العراق
ووفد على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
إضافةً إلى وفد نصارى نجران
لكن هذا النص منحول
كان فيه شيء من التقدير في الكنائس النسطورية الشرقية
لكن تجد مؤرخي الكنائس الأرمانية أو الكنائس البيزنطية
أو الكنائس السريانية الغربية أو اليعقوبية
كانت تنظر إلى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وإلى الإسلام
في السياق السلبي
وخاصةً مؤرخي الإمبراطورية البيزنطية
مثلًا أهم مؤرخ بيزنطي، هو مؤرخ البلاط البيزنطي
اسمه «ثيوفان المعترف»
ويتكلم مثلًا عن أن في هذا الزمان حسب التقويم اليوناني أو الإسكندر
أنه نظهر من بين «السراقنة» رجل يزعم النبوة
وأنه ينتمي إلى ذرية إسماعيل بن إبراهيم عليهم السلام
ثم يجي يقسمهم إلى «مضر» إلى «ربيعة» إلى «قريش»
إلى باقي التسلسل القبلي وأن هؤلاء ظهر من بينهم هذا الرجل
وأنه قادهم إلى بدعة جديدة
هو لا يُقر أنه الدين الصحيح، هو يقر أنها بدعة
ثم يبدأ في محاولة القدح في نبوة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
على عكس مؤرخ نسطوري في العراق
اللي ذكرته لك، اللي هو مؤرخ «تاريخ سيرت»
يتكلم عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في السياق للتوراتي الإيجابي
وأن هرقل اللي هو الإمبراطور البيزنطي
اللي أرسل له الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كتاب يدعوه للإسلام
استدعى قساوسته أو الأساقفة أو رجال الكنيسة
استدعاهم وسألهم، لماذا هذه الهزائم المتكررة؟
من هو هذا الرجل؟ وما الذي يدعو له؟
قالوا هذه مشيئة الله التي وردت في العهد القديم
فقال أجل دعوهم، ولا تحاولوا أن تثيروهم
لأن هذه إرادة الله. وهزيمتنا -هو يتكلم عن نفسه- إرادة الله
فإرادة الله حسب تصور النصراني، كانت السبب في انتصارات المسلمين
ونزاعات النصارى أنفسهم وذنوب النصارى أنفسهم
كانت السبب في انتصارات بنو إسماعيل
وفي ظهور نبوة محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
فهي دائمًا ترتبط في نصوص العهد القديم
ومحاولة تفسير نصوص العهد القديم
لكنها أيضًا لا تخرج عن التصور السلبي
اللي يحاول يصوّر العرب في صورة الشعب الهمجي
الشعب اللي ينشر الدمار، اللي ينشر الخراب
ثم يعود بعض هؤلاء المؤرخين اللي يعترفون
أن هؤلاء الغزاة نشروا الأمن والسلام
بل أن من هؤلاء المؤرخين من يعترف أن هؤلاء الطائيين أو الهاجريين
كانوا متسامحين مع كنائسنا. لم يحاولوا أن يستثيروا كنائسنا
أو يجبروننا على دينهم أو على معتقدهم
ولذلك حكم هؤلاء الإسماعيليين والهاجريين
أفضل لنا من حكم البيزنطيين، أفضل لنا من حكم الفرس
لأنهم يتعاملون بسياسة واقعية
لا تحاول أن تتدخل في شؤون الكنيسة
أو تفرض دين أو معتقد جديد على هذه الكنيسة
هذا جزء من هؤلاء المؤرخين
بالنسبة لليهود، كيف كانوا يشوفونا؟
اليهود كانوا أقلية بشكل عام
وكانوا موجودين ومتناثرين ما بين بلاد الشام، فلسطين ومصر
ولهم أصلًا بعض التراث، وإن كان قليل جدًّا، ماهو بذاك الكثرة
فلذلك ما كانوا بذلك الوزن
اللي يجعل دراسة نصوصهم أو تراثهم؛ تجلب اهتمام المؤرخين
أنا شخصيًّا لا أخفيك، أنا ما اتجهت لدراسة التراث اليهودي أو العبري
طبعًا هناك كتابات عبرية عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
أو عن هذه الفترة المبكرة
بالنسبة للصحابة كيف نظروا اليهم؟
نظروا إليهم على أنهم أتباع هذا الرجل
شافوهم كحواريي عيسى وللا؟
أهم شخصية نظرت لها بعض الكتابات النصرانية
اللي هي شخصية «عمر بن الخطاب» رضي الله عنه
خاصة بعد ما قدم لفتح بيت المقدس، العام السادس عشر للهجرة تقريبًا
استقبله أسقف بيت المقدس «صفرينيوس»
و«صفرينيوس» بالمناسبة هو من أوائل من تكلم عن انتصارات «السراقنة»
وعن نشرهم الرعب في فلسطين، أو في بلاد الشام في وقته
وأنهم خطر داهم يهدد أمته
وكانت له ثلاث خطب
واحدة منها مثلًا في مولد المسيح، ووحدة في رأس السنة
في الثلاث الخطب كان يندد بغزوات «السراقنة»
وكان يحذر أمته من مغبة الاستسلام لهذا الخطر الداهم
وأنه يجب التصدي له
ولكن مع ذلك، ستجد أن هذا الرجل هو من يعقد
اتفاقية تسليم بيت المقدس
ويتفاوض مع الخليفة «عمر بن الخطاب»
هذا الحدث المهم اللي هو مجيء الخليفة بنفسه
لاستلام المدينة المقدسة. وما تبعها من اتفاقيات مهمة
اللي هو عهد الأمان أو العهدة العمرية
اللي ضمنت للنصارى حريتهم ومعتقداتهم
وحماية حتى الأماكن المقدسة
نظر إليه بعض المكونات النصرانية أو حتى اليهودية
على أن هو المسيح المنتظر
لكن لما رأوه يأكل لحم الجمل؛ اتضح لهم أن هو غير ذلك
تخيل، لحم الجمل!
قالوا أن هذا ليس هو المسيح الموعود
هم كانوا يتصورون اليهود أن عمر هو المسيح الموعود
وكان لقبه الفاروق مذكور؟
هو فيه خلاف في لقب الفاروق
هل الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم أطلق عليه اللقب هذا؟
هو كان حديث
أو أنه مرتبط بالنصارى أنفسهم
لكن لاحظ أن بعض المكونات اليهودية
كانت تمر إليه على أنه قد يكون هو المسيح المنتظر
فلما رأوه يأكل لحم الجمل؛ قالوا ليس هذا هو المسيح
يعني هذه الشخصية
الخليفة «علي بن أبي طالب» رضي الله عنه
هناك نص مهم عنه في إحدى المصادر السريانية
اللي تناولت التاريخ لفترة الصراع بين «علي» و«معاوية»
كان يسميه «أبو تراب»
«أبو تراب» هو لقب أطلقه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
على «علي بن ابي طالب» رضي الله عنه. وكان لقب محبب إليه
اللقب هذا استخدمه مؤرخ سرياني شبه مجهول
دوّن إحدى المصادر المبكرة في القرن السابع الهجري
عن سيرة أحد الرهبان اسمه «مكسيموس المعترف»
وفي ثنايا هذا المصدر، يتكلم عن عدة معارك
عن «الجمل» عن «صفين» عن صراع «أبو تراب» مع «معاوية»
ويقصد «أبو تراب» «علي بن أبي طالب» رضي الله عنه
طبعًا لكنه ما حاول أن يفسره في سياق لاهوتي
أو في سياق توراتي. أو يضفي عليه تفسير
يتخيله مثلًا المسيح، أو يتخيله نبي ظهر
أو يتخيله بأكبر من شخصية إنسانية أو بشرية حقيقية
الحين أغلب حديثنا كان عن بيزنطة، الفرس، الحبشة
هل فيه أقوام ثانية كانت تذكر أو تدون جزيرة العربية والعرب؟
الصين، الهند، الأقباط؟
احنا ودنا نرجع أو نستذكر خارطة العالم القديم عند ظهور الإسلام
أو في بداية القرن السابع الميلادي
جزيرة العرب تقع في القلب من هذا العالم
محاطة بعدد من الكيانات السياسية، اللي ذكرتها لك قبل قليل
الفرس، الروم، مملكة الحبشة
في أقصى الشرق أسرة «تانق» الصينية
هذه الأمم أو هذه الكيانات أو هذه المجتمعات
كانت تعيش فترة استقرار، وبالتالي كان لديها حركة تدوين
تدوين في التاريخ، تدوين في اللاهوت، تدوين في الأدب
جزء من اهتمامات مؤرخي هذه الأمم
عن ما يحدث في الجزيرة العربية
أنا لا أتكلم عن الفترة الإسلامية، حتى ما قبل الإسلام
لو اطلعت على مشروع أخرجته دائرة الملك عبدالعزيز
قبل عدة سنوات، اسمه «الجزيرة العربية في المصادر الكلاسيكية»
ستجد أن هذه المصادر دونت كثير من المعلومات
المهمة والمتنوعة عن الجزيرة العربية، وعن سكانها
حتى في عصور ما قبل الميلاد
وأنا أقصد بذلك المصادر الكلاسيكية الإغريقية أو اليونان القدماء
والرومانية أو اللاتين القدماء؛ كتبوا
ذات الكلام ينسحب على المصادر اللي أرّخت
للجزيرة العربية، أرّخت للإسلام
تكلمت عن العرب وعن المسلمين خلال هذه الفترة
الصينية من الشرق، الفارسية، السريانية، أرمانية
اليونانية البيزنطية أو يونانية العصور الوسطى
ومصادر قبطية ومصادر لاتينية في الغرب
كل هذه المصادر تضمنت معلومات مهمة
معلومات بعضها معاصر
وأنا ذكرت لك قبل قليل، أقدم مصدر أشار للإسلام
وإلى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم، كان بعد وفاته بسنتين
لذلك هذه المصادر سبقت حتى المصادر أو التاريخية العربية
في التأريخ للعرب أنفسهم أو لظهورهم
فلذلك ستجد إشارات كثيرة ومتنوعة
كانت مادة خصبة للاستشراق
لمحاولة إعادة دراسة السرد التاريخي
عن العرب، عن الإسلام، عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
بعدة أطروحات بعضها سلبي وبعضها إيجابي
مثلًا احنا ودنا نتكلم عن مدرسة
اسمها المدرسة التنقيحية أو مدرسة المراجعين الجدد
ظهرت في الغرب، وتحديدًا في بريطانيا
في النصف الثاني من السبعينيات الميلادية
هذه المدرسة اسموا أنفسهم التشكيكيين أو المراجعين
قالوا نحن نريد أن نعيد مراجعة السياق الكامل للإسلام
الدين، التاريخ، اللغة، وما إلى ذلك
وأن كل هذا السرد قابل للشك، بما فيه القرآن نفسه
أول شخصية يعتبر مؤسس لهذه المدرسة اسمه «جون وانسبرو»
«جون وانسبرو» هو مستشرق أمريكي
لكن كان يدرس في جامعة لندن
وله كتاب اسمه «دراسات قرآنية»
طرح أطروحة أن النص القرآني الموجود اليوم
ليس هو النص القرآني الذي نزل على محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وأنه ليس النص القرآني صحيح
وأن هذا النص استغرق حوالي 200 عام
حتى يخرج إلى صورته النهائية
وأنه مر بحالات من الحذف والإضافة والتعديل
الدراسات الأثرية، المخطوطات التي اكتشفت
يعني مخطوطات القرآن المبكرة
مثل مخطوط جامعة «صنعاء»
مثل المخطوط اللي اكتشف في جامعة ألمانية، لا يحضرني اسمها
مثل مخطوط جامعة «بيمنق هام» وأنا شخصيًّا اطلعت عليه
أثبتت أن هذه الأضروحة غير صحيحة
وأن النص القرآني هو نفس النص القرآني الذي وصلنا اليوم
كما يقول المولى عز وجل «وَمَا يَنْطِقُ عَنِ الْهَوَى. إِنْ هُوَ إِلَّا وَحْيٌ يُوحَى»
من هذا الرجل انطلقت مدرسة
محاولة إعادة صياغات التاريخ الإسلامي المبكر
وفق هذه المصادر المتنوعة
فخرج كتاب اسمه «الهاجرية» عام سبعة وسبعون للميلاد
كتاب «الهاجرية» اشترك في كتابته مؤرخين من أساتذة جامعة «أكسفورد»
«مايكل كوك» المؤرخ البريطاني والمؤرخة الدنماركية «باتريشا كرون»
قالوا هذا الكتاب احنا نكتبه، لا نكتبه لكم كمسلمين أو كعرب
احنا نكتبه لمجتمعاتنا الأوربية والغربية
ونقول لهم أن تاريخ الإسلام اللي تقرؤونه
القرآن، محمد، عمر، أبو بكر، كل هؤلاء الأشخاص، وكل هذه السرديات
في نظرنا أنها قابلة للشك وأنها قد لا تكون صحيحة
كيف يكون ذلك؟ خلونا نقرأ تاريخ هذا الإسلام أو هذه المنظومة
من خلال ما دوّن عنه في مصادر الأمم الأخرى
المصادر السريانية، اليونانية، الأرمانية، القبطية وهكذا
فهم قدموا نظرية تنظر إلى أن ما كان اسمهم مسلمين، كانوا هاجريين
وأن محمد عليه الصلاة والسلام قد يكون تأثر بالمجتمع اليهودي
أو حتى النصراني لمحاولة خلق منظومة دينية جديدة وتكاملة
وأنه لم يكن أصلًا شيء اسمه إسلام
سألتني قبل شوي عن مصطلح الإسلام
دليلهم في ذلك، المصطلحات والسرديات
التي وردت في كتابات مؤرخي الأمم المعاصرة
سواءً الأمم المغلوبة التي خضعت الحكم العرب
أو الأمم المعاصرة مثل مؤرخي القارة الأوربية أو الإمبراطورية البيزنطية
هذا الطرح لقي نقد من مستشرقين آخرين، ونقد قوي
بعد ما خرج الكتاب، هذا ظهر مستشرق اسكتلندي بريطاني
اسمه «مونتقمري وات» انتقد هذا الكتاب
طبعًا «مونتقمري وات» لمن لا يعلم
هو مؤرخ كان يعمل في جامعة «أدنبرة» وله كتاب اسمه...
طبعًا هو دوّن سيرة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
في مجلدين «محمد في مكة» و«محمد في المدينة»
وانتقد كتاب «الهاجرية»
قال: أنا أرى -هو طبعًا يتصور- أن ما قدمه الباحثان الشابان
عبث أكاديمي. لأن وفق منظورهم
لا بد أن ننسف العهد القديم والعهد الجديد، كيف ذلك؟
طبعًا هو كتب مراجعة نقدية في عدة صفحات
كيف يكون ذلك؟ طبعًا هو يقول
إذا كان الإنجيل لم تدوّن نسخه إلا بعد سبعين للميلاد
فبالتالي يجب أن نشك في نفس نشأة الإنجيل
إذا كان العهد القديم وصلنا عبر نسخ متعددة
فيجب أن نشك في العهد القديم
ونشك حتى في الأنبياء أنفسهم، وفق هذه الأطروحة
فبالتالي ما يقدمه الباحثان هو عبث أكاديمي، غير صحيح
مؤرخين آخرين انتقدوا هذه الأطروحات
آخر شخص يمكن تكتب بتوسع و باستفاضة
ومعاصر لنا اليوم اسمه «روبرت هويلند»
«روبرت هويلند» هذا تلميذ عند «باتريشا كرون»
درس تحت إشرافها هذه المصادر
وأخرج كتاب، الكتاب للتّو تُرجم، ونُشر وبُيع في معرض الرياض
الكتاب اسمه «الإسلام كما رآه الآخرون»
ماذا يقول هذا الرجل في الكتاب؟
يقول: أنا لا أتفق مع أطروحتك يا أستاذتي
أنا عندي تصور مختلف أو موضوعي
مثلما أن المسلمين لهم سردياتهم، فالمغلوبين لهم سردياتهم
طبعًا هو طوّر نقاشاته في كتابات أخرى
وفي كتب أخرى وفي إنتاج آخر
يعني كتابه «الإسلام كما رآه الآخرون»
جمع كل أو جُل ما كُتب عن الإسلام وكُتب عن العرب
في الفترة المبكرة هذه
من المصادر الصينية، من المصادر الفارسية
من المصادر السريانية من المصادر الأرمانية وهكذا
وجمّعها وحلّلها وناقشها ووثقها
وخرج في النهاية أن هذه هي وجهة نظر الشعوب الأخرى
طوّر هذه الدراسات إلى كتاب آخر اسمه «في سبيل الله»
والكتاب هذا خرج عام 2015. يقول في كتابه
أنا في هذا الكتاب أحاول أن أؤرخ للفتوحات العربية الإسلامية
من خلال وجهة نظري للطرفين المنتصر والمغلوب
بالتالي ليس بالضرورة أن ما يقوله المنتصر يشرح الحقيقة كاملة
مثلما ليس بالضرورة أن ما دونه المتغلب ينقل لنا الحقيقة كما هي
فبالتالي الصورة لا تكتمل، إلا من خلال أخذ وجهتي النظر
فقدم لنا عمل تاريخي متكامل اعتمد فيه
على مصادر إسلامية ومصادر المغلوبين
بل أنه وصل إلى نتائج مهمة
من أهم هذه النتائج: أن هناك تشابه في سرديات الفتوحات نفسها
فيه مؤرخ آخر، وقبل ما ننتقل لمؤرخ آخر
بل إن «روبرت هويلند» له مقال عن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
في كتابات مؤرخي النصارى
في القرن السابع الميلادي أو في القرن الأول الهجري
حاول أن يناقش هذه الأطروحات، اللي ذكرت لك قبل قليل
ووصل إلى نتيجة أن ليس بالضرورة أن تعبر عن شخص كما هو
بقدر ما تعبر عن تصورات أخرى
لم تعيش في النطاق الجغرافي أو السياسي أو الحضاري
اللي كان عايش فيها عليه الصلاة والسلام
بل أن هذه الأطروحات كانت حتى متناقضة فيما بينها
المؤرخ الآخر اللي انتقد أطروحة «باتريشا كرون»
هو مؤرخ بريطاني معاصر موجود اليوم
في جامعة لندن اسمه «هيو كينيدي»
«هيو كينيدي» ألّف كتاب في بداية الألفية
اسمه «فتوحات العرب الكبرى»
طبعًا لما أتى في مقدمة الكتاب قال
هناك من أرّخ للفتوحات، ومن أرّخ لظهور الإسلام
في الكثير من الأطروحات الغربية
ومن أهمها كتاب «الهاجرية»
كتاب «الهاجرية» يطرح أطروحة مختلفة
تنقض السرد التاريخي للإسلام
وأن ما ذكره المسلمون في تواريخهم غير صحيح
هو يقول، لكن في وجهة نظري أنا ليس بالضرورة
أن ما قالته «كرون» صحيح
أنا أقول -هذا يقوله هو عن لسانه- وجهة نظري
أن كثير من سرديات المغلوبين وخاصة المصادر الأرمانية والسريانية
تتفق مع كثير من سرديات التراث الإسلامي
بما يؤكد مصداقية هذا التراث
ثم وضع مجموعة نماذج للفتوحات العربية
في بلاد الرافدين وفي الهضبة الإيرانية
مثلًا فتح مدينة مثل «تستر»
حتى التفاصيل فيه توافق
بين الرواية الإسلامية وبين الرواية الأرمانية والرواية السريانية
تحديدًا السريانية
مثل مقتل آخر الشاهات الفرس «يزدجرد»
فيه تشابه كبير بين الرواية الإسلامية وحتى روايات الفرس أنفسهم
فيه كتاب «خداينامه»
أو كتابات المصادر الأرمانية والسريانية أيضًا المعاصرة
فيه مؤرخ أيضًا لا يقل أهمية عن هؤلاء
مؤرخ ألماني، توفي قبل سنتين اسمه «هارالد موتسكي»
طبعًا «هارالد موتسكي» تخصص في الدراسات الإسلامية
في دراسة الحديث. وتصدى للأطروحات الغربية القديمة أو الحديثة
فيه أطروحات غربية قديمة منذ أيام «قولد تسهير» هذا مستشرق مجري
و«جوزيف شاخت» مستشرق نمساوي، درس على الحديث
وطرح أطروحات غريبة وغير مقبولة حتى عندنا
أن الحديث لم يكن مصدر التشريع
وأن التشريع الإسلامي اللاحق اللي أظهر المذاهب الفقهية
كان عبارة عن مجموعة من القوانين الرومانية
التشريع المبكر
وأن لم يكن هناك عودة للقرآن إلا حينما ظهرت المذاهب الفقهية
ثم جاء مستشرق ألماني اللي اسمه «هارالد موتسكي»
نقض هذه الأطروحات. سواءً في الحديث
أو سواء في دراسة التراث التاريخي الإسلامي
لأنه درس من ناحيتين: التراث الحديث والتراث التاريخي
و«موتسكي» يقول أن هناك شبكة واسعة من العلماء، من الرواة
شبكة رواة، شبكة علمية نقلت مرويات ضخمة وكثيرة جدًّا
ليس شخص واحد مثلًا ينقل لك أحداث غزوة «اليرموك»
أو أحداث غزوة «بدر»
ليس شخص واحد ينقل لك حديث صحيح عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بل أن هناك شبكة واسعة تنقل لك كل هذا التراث
وأن هذه الشبكة تنقل لك هذا التراث، بصيغ تكاد تكون متطابقة
فمستحيل أن كل هؤلاء يكذبون
وبالتالي الأطروحة الغربية أو أطروحة «كرون» هذه
في رأيي أنها أطروحة ساذجة
غير قادرة أصلًا على فهم جذور الخلفية الحضارية
والخلفية الدينية والخلفية العلمية والفكرية
للمجتمع العربي خلال هذه الفترة المبكرة
شكرًا جزيلًا
الله يسلمك
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لأيمن الحمّادي وعادل باعطيه في إعداد الحلقة
وهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
وفي التسجيل الصوتي عبدالعزيز المزّي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
والتلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي التحرير محمد نور شمّت
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
وفي إدارة التحرير أسيل با عبدالله
هذا فنجان
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقادم
ترجمة نانسي قنقر